day four of the Croatia rapid and Blitz
the third stop on the grand chess tour
the legend Gary Kasparov had a tough day
of Fast and Furious Blitz while Maxine
Bashir lagrav closed the gap on
tournament leader Jana pomnishi leaving
all to play for with the title on the
line the tension is high as the champion
will be crowned the final day of
exciting action coming up next
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone and welcome back to
Zagreb for the final day of action of
the Croatian rapid and Blitz we're in
front of glavney colador the main
Central Station connecting the city to
All Points around this amazing country
well the only thing faster than the
trains will be the player's hands as
they have nine rounds of exciting Blitz
and to call all the action we're going
to jump to the studio with Christian and
Yasser
welcome back everybody two beautiful
Zagreb Croatia the host of the Third Leg
of the 2021 Grand Chester what a Scenic
Place to continue after our summer of
Chess at the Grand chess tour here from
the studio I am Grand Master Christian
kirila and I'm joined by Grandmaster
Yasser sarawan Yasser good morning good
morning Christian as always a pleasure
to recall the action with you and
Maurice hello everyone and Welcome to
our live coverage of the grand Chester
Croatia I tell you it's been chess Wars
going on but as we started the blitz
yesterday
it was two stories the return of Gary
Kasparov oh my goodness an epic Veil and
an extraordinary jockeying for position
for first let's take a look at our
standings Christian the standings right
now look incredible we have janapomnia
she with 17 points in the Seoul
leadership position then closely be
behind we have Maxim vashir lagrav yes
sir what do you think of this absolutely
take a look at the second column as you
see that Jan scores six out of nine but
Maxine got six and a half and crept
closer half a point but also a nation
Christian Anish is doing amazing with 15
and a half points only one and a half
Point behind the leader vishwanathan
unknown the five-time world champion the
tiger of Madras is on 14 and a half
points tied for fourth position also is
Jan Christoph Duda with 14 and a half
points Alexander grishuk and chakri
armamediarov are tied for sixth position
with 13 points we have Anton korob with
11 and a half points in eighth position
Kasparov as you were mentioning Yasser a
lackluster performance yesterday he is
in ninth position with 10 and a half
points Jordan van forest in 10th
position with nine points and our format
Christian
we had for the first three days we had
rapid gaming 25 minutes with a 10 second
increment those days are over right now
we have the blitz portion we have Blitz
game in five minutes with a two second
increment absolutely no draw offers the
players will have to find a repetition a
stalemate or they will have to have
absolutely no material left on the
chessboard in the rapid portion the
scoring system is a bit different we
have two points for a win one point for
a draw and zero points for a loss those
rapid games are extremely valuable in
the blitz section we have the standard
scoring system 1.4 win half a point for
a draw and zero points for a loss and we
have a very handsome price fund of a
hundred and fifty thousand US Dollars
and our schedule is very easy it is our
final day of Blitz we have nine rounds
from rounds 10 to 18 team and in case of
a tie there will be playoffs Christian
let's dive a little deeper into tie
breaks we're going to play more chess in
the event of a tie for first place in
any of the 2021 rapid and Blitz
grandchester events there will be a
playoff amongst all the players involved
in the tie if we have two players died
then we're going to have a rapid double
round robin a bit of a faster rapid than
what we played in the first three days
game in 10 minutes with a 5 Second
increment if three or more players are
tied then we're going to have a blitz
round robin game in 5 minutes with a 2
second increment if we cannot separate
these players even after that if the
players are tied after the round robin
we're going to jump straight into the
Armageddon that's going to be 5 minutes
for white and 4 minutes for black no
increment no delay and black wins with a
draw the action will be extremely fast
and furious though heart palpitations
for me and now let's go over to Zagreb
Croatia with our colleague Maurice
Ashley good morning from St Louis
Maurice good morning
good morning Yasser and Christensen will
harp palpitations indeed will be the
order of the day for the players playing
on this last day with nine rounds of
Blitz very close at the top I just saw
Gary Kasparov walk by and I'm wondering
what is this great Legend thinking right
now he's not playing for first anymore
he's playing for respect a lot of noobs
online dissing The Legend Gary Kasparov
come on the guys gotten so many titles
you can only wish you had one of those
but a player who will be looking to get
this title is Jana pumnichi he's been
leading from beginning to end he did
have a little slip though in the Blitz
and let's take a look at those crazy
performances that did occur yesterday he
won his first game got out the gate
immediately keeping his Edge over Maxime
and Anish Geary as well as Christian
Duda who will feature in this highlight
package in a moment but in the very next
game he dropped blood and lost ended up
having a niche take over in Round in
game two
and here it was he actually was tied
after the second round then after that
he started to slip
showing that he is indeed mortal as he
slipped back slowly in the event
and Anish took over as Maxime Rose to
the top and then Jan nepomachi there you
see tied at second place
that was definitely the slow performance
for him as he started his rise once
again you see him there tied with Maxim
Anish and Jan Christoph Duda who simply
came out of nowhere in fact and then he
continued to start winning and it was
him and Maxime with a tale of winning
games trying to separate themselves from
the pack a niche staying relevant of
course but they kept their Torrid Pace
did mvl and nefo you see the two of them
at the top at 16 and then once more at
the very end you see Yan taking over the
lead to have a slim half a point lead
over the rest of the field
we see the line score here as nepo with
the really good start in round one but
then games two three and four only
scoring a half a point and then rounds
five through nine getting it done with
four and a half blistering points out of
five certainly that's the kind of
performance he's gonna look to do today
without those two goose eggs though if
he could keep that up he should win the
event but watch out for mercurial Maxime
as he's playing Amazing Blitz right now
will he catch nepo and cause the
playoffs we'll let you know here from
Zagreb guys thank you Maurice indeed a
real jockeying position for position
throughout day one and look who's first
to arrive for this round ten the legend
is she Anand there's mvl so getting
ready for this uh let's just quickly get
to the pairing shall we Christian lay
the table for round ten we have Mama
diaro versus Maxim vashier
we have Duda versus grishu vishwanathan
versus Anish giri and Gary Kasparov
versus Jordan van Forest Yasser which
one are we going to focus on to start a
day Shaq versus MBL will be our Marquee
matchup we'll keep Anton koraboff and
nepo in our pockets as our backup for
this round let's look at that start of
the round soon coming up in Croatia
round 10 again this is our final day of
Blitz for this Croatian Grand chess tour
Third Leg of the grand chest tour and I
tell you a big shout out to the
organizers in Croatia it looks like they
really staged a beautiful event and look
at Anton smirking as he gets ready to
take on the leader
I tell you Anton has had he's enjoying
himself yeah a roller coaster ride in uh
his interview with Maurice he said he's
just going to sit back and enjoy his
match up with Gary Kasparov a game that
he actually won and he's just but he's
there he's throwing the paddies
Christian oh absolutely he's definitely
there I I mean his games all of them are
so explosive so double-edged that
anything can happen and I did pick him
as the winner of the bits of course
that's quite a far-fetched thought right
now as we enter the last nine rounds but
still here she was playing amazing but
look at who's this here this is the man
I picked as the winner of the Blitz and
I want to say I was so close I mean I'm
really proud of my pick I couldn't be
more wrong which means I will never be
as wrong as I am right now today ever
again on a grand chest tour poor Gary
Kasparov and I know Gary very very well
and trust me when he has had a bad day
at the office he doesn't sleep well so I
mean I just wonder what kind of shape
he's in as Marie said at the top of the
show he's playing for respect and we're
off and we are off indeed and let me
just bring up on my board our featured
matchup
and which is the one between Shaq and
mvl and it's a very standard
groomfeld not a surprise there
now the question is are we going to see
that repetition once again off the road
to B1
2 E2 we're going to take the pawn with C
takes D4 a quint wave five Queen A5
check I think we're going to see a
repetition we might be moving out of
this game very quickly because let's
just wait this line of the grunfeld is
so
extremely forcing
that from mvl's point of view he has no
choice but to continue in the way he is
playing I believe we're going straight
into that one and now Bishop G5
hitting the bishop on D4 Queen takes D4
big threat but also Bishop takes E7
I believe Knight C6 might be the move
yeah the most standard yeah
but Knight to C6 Rook to C7 how is that
position
Rook to C7 and then do you have a good
way to defend against Rook takes C6
don't think so maybe Knight C6 is not
the right move in the position but I'm
sure mvl will
kind of so understand what needs to be
done well again with the double attack
you you tend to think well Bishop F6
would drop back as well as E7 E5 would
defend against both threats the threat
of Bishop takes E7 as well as Queen
takes D4
especially maybe bishop chief gosh darn
it it's too early in the morning for me
to re recall what the theory is I can
only imagine the players having to Rook
d8 is the main move Rook d8 I think is
the main move yeah Rook d8 makes a lot
of sense because Rook d8 not only
attacks Pardon Me Not only defends the
bishop but it also opens up a discovered
threat of Bishop takes F2 check so Rook
d8 uh for sure and he is going for it he
has played it Rook to the eighth so
we're not going to see that Forest line
that is a good sign for us yes Queen to
C1 usually has to follow up to get that
Queen off the D file which and I believe
he has played it and now we need to see
knightway six that is key yeah and that
too has been played so Quincy once
prevented
the development Knight C6 that's why we
saw it in Knight to A6 Rook to C8
attacking the Queen the reason behind
this is that you want to get that Rook
off the seventh rank the Ruka on B7 the
way you're going to do that is via
Knight to A6 Knight to C5 you're going
to leave that Rook on d8 uh unprotected
but you're going to play Knight to C5
this is actually what he's going for yes
and he's done his exactly as you advised
not moving The Rook on d8 but instead
making a counter attack against Bishop
takes d8 was played now we're going to
see Knight takes B7 again this looks
like one of those really really long
forcing lines that grunfeld defense
players it's like you've got to know
your stat at the end of the day but if
you play All the Right Moves it usually
Peters out to a draw I think to be
honest we should make an educated
decision right out and jump to a
different game because I don't see much
history in this one yeah it would appear
to me somewhat similar the Knight will
likely want to reroute itself
uh to d8 and to E6 and again it's four
versus four so a good time to maybe
switch Knight C5 was played let's just
take a look at what other games a niche
Anand
I believe one that we're understanding
that is getting quite fun is the one
between Gary Castro and Jordan and as
you are mentioning uh Garrick hasbrov
lost against Jordan in the first round
yesterday right beautiful a beautiful
night or that set the tone for the whole
day because people were just targeting
that variation of the neither so now he
has his good way to get his revenge a
scotch a scotch that he made famous from
his 1990 World Chess Championship match
against Anatoly karpov
he wheeleded out the old 200 year old
variation we called the scotch and with
success
against Anatoly D7 D6 by Jordan as he
looks to open up the diagonal for his
Bishop trying to complete his
development
first impression is I need to do
something to
mess this queen and Bishop up
the queen on B4 you mean yes I'm
thinking something like Knight and
Bishop to D2 or trying to play with A3
and both B4 it's not exactly I don't
exactly see how
I am supposed to exploit
the queen on B4 the bishop on C5 looks
like a a poor construction but where's
the refutation and the problem is that
if you go A3 what are you uh trying to
I'm afraid of Leia's black well I think
I'm just gonna go seven a queen B6 Queen
B6 okay and so A3 Queen B6 and if I
continue being before the bishop will
drop in on D4 and he'll tickle The Rook
as well as the pawn on E5 that feels
wrong Knight F3 there would be massive
trades on E5 and that feels wrong
which kind of leaves Bishop takes G6 but
I'm I'm disbelieving that
well there we go that's a that's a one
way of trying to exploit
the the queen and the bishop at Knight
B3 with the idea Bishop D2 uh so we're
I'm looking pardon me I should say I'm
looking at Knight takes E5 Bishop D2
Queen B6 Bishop to A5
Queen A6 Knight C5 Queen A5 I still
don't excuse me I still don't see the
follow-up uh Knight takes E5 do you see
a refutation I do not see it 95 Bishop
D2 queen bees there has to be one it
just feels like there's everything
Gary's got some devilish plan in mind it
doesn't seem like there's something in
the air something may be connected with
that porno Nation but he took it we're
going to find uh fine show me the answer
in just a second we immediately played
A3 we are in the show me state of
Missouri oh there we go this is it well
at least an attempt Queen B6 Queen B6
and now I'm going to take on C5 Knight
C5 Queen C5 and then Bishop to E3 and
I'm just going to try to
take your extra down the road as much as
possible
yep and that's where we're going and
we're going to see a queen probably land
on A4
which has happened by the way and again
it's a pawn I mean there's a night on
the E5 Knight on E5 is anchored by a
Pawn on D6 that's usually great
compensation for the two Bishops and
Jordan's basically saying I don't know
Gary looks a little strange to me if I
play Bishop eh there is a bishop H6
sighting
but then you can reply with Knight to G6
and that's not going to force the loss
of the exchange I'm not sure while the
cat's away the mice will play as we say
uh Bishop h69 G6
F4
idea if you take my Bishop to play F5
look speculative but this this is what
Gary needs to do with the queen stuck
over there on the okay he's done
different moves right now Bishop to D4
F6 Bishop takes E5 wow now we're going
straight back that Queen on A4 can we do
that how are you going to do that
so it very much depends on what he takes
with on e56
D6 this is a D6 Point really let's just
suppose
then I go C5
well he quickly took away the F Pawn he
he took with the F Pawn and then Jordan
made the very natural developing move
Bishop F5 and again garish
still fighting to show compensation 35
seconds no oh but he could take on F5
and take on
E5 and that's exactly and if you go Rook
takes E5 he's got Queen
we have a queen landing on D7 right now
so we don't have
we have a lot of attacks on those oh my
gosh
by the queen to B3 goes to B3 now
and now
Gary's clock management it was a an epic
fail in day one of the blitz under 10
seconds now no you just that that now
he's going to be playing on increment
absolutely for the rest of this game I'm
thinking it's time to play H7 H6 just to
make some Luft but that's going to give
me another Pawn on C7 and I'm going to
take that well I always a question in
these major piece end games
whose passers are the most effective E5
E4 is coming fast
yeah Jordan's uh what what is Jordan's
clock like right now entering his final
minute King h8 and very quickly Gary
Rook F1 to E1
both players back ranks are vulnerable
and Gary intuits that
it's about
whoa Gary could have taken on E5 and he
would have definitely had the better of
a drawn position but he played the most
aggressive way C5 okay that's a good
move
yeah he didn't need to play Queen E3
Queen E3 was a trap Queen E3 would have
been wait a minute Queen takes E5 yes
Rook that can be taken I am going to
take back on F1
ah yes thank you that is two pawns up he
understands and the same thing Rook F1
check Miss met by Rook takes F1 you
could take the queen but
uh The Rook on f8 isn't hanging so Gary
now two full pawns up he does have a
winning position but it's all about the
clock now it's all about the clock 27
seconds for Jordan
Jordan oh that's why Gary yeah Gary
blundered A4 he just forgot that Rook
takes A4 uh whoa B6 and Rook G5 Queen F3
oh Beast
oh
ticks Queen takes B1 is met by Queen DHS
we're going to see the first Victory
almost Gary Kasparov
okay in this tournament oh we're very
beautiful what other games do we have
what's happening in nepo
Shaq versus mvl I'm just looking pardon
me I'm just looking at the game between
Anton and nepo nepo's our tournament
leader it's a crazy game it looks like
that is winning by the way
looks like nepo is winning tonight who
has won that game okay sorry but let's
go to Mama diarov because mamadiaro is
actually nursing a pawn up advantage
against npl not be winning this should
still be a theoretical draw I'm not 100
sure F4 F5 once you get an F5 check
no you're right it should be a drug it
should be just because I'm going Brook
is coming to H1 H1 very yeah that's the
problem the counter play against the H4
Pawn is too Swift I can I can start with
you know Rook D6 doesn't threaten E5
yet
uh could you tell me the times of the
players uh Christian yes 33 seconds for
mvl who is uh
who is in need to make a move right now
and 23 seconds for chakra armamidearov
the desirable Rook E3 is met by F5
that's the problem with Rook E3 Shaq
Saudi was just about to play rookie
three when he recognized that F5 E5 F4
check and messes him up so he played
Rook D6 now I'm expecting just the king
to to drop back to avoid the E5 threat
a dancing of the Kings yes the dance for
the Kings now both players marking time
with their Rooks for the moment now
Blitz players would play a move like
Rook B6 there to bring to draw the black
Rook a little closer to the white king
and now we finally say it now the idea
from White's point of view is to get in
the break again in the move pardon me
for if I've checked King goes to age six
and then something like Rook to F7 in
order to to pick off
oh
stalemate there's another way of making
a draw the first time we must take on F5
you have to be very careful we've seen a
Mad King beautiful nice okay that's a
nice one ah look at the two players is
that Rook D3 check just when Shaq's oops
had jumped a notch or two
wow okay very eventful round we'll get
you know the scores and things like that
all settled
a nice start I'm so happy for Gary
absolutely and he needed that break you
could see it on his face he felt the
relief immediately as his opponent
resigned as his opponent extended his
arm to shake hands he was so happy he
bolted out of his chair and went to uh
to his uh resting area with his second
Michael korsakovski but we'll be jumping
to Marie shortly even Jordan was quite
happy yeah
he lost but he was happy for Gary
exactly exactly but it was a big game
for nepo too because he had the black
pieces against Anton he's nursing a half
a point lead he won mvl saved the
position but now Trails by a full point
keep that in mind as we again we're
preparing
drew his game against Anish giri so
Manish was a point and a half behind the
leader so now he's two points behind the
leader Nepal that's right that's right
Nebo is extending his lead more
definitely a beautiful game and I'm sure
Maurice will have a lot of insights
about that one the one that we missed
yes indeed again we're just waiting for
Maurice to get all set up we had had
some technical issues but overall I want
to say I'm really really pleased with
how we've managed to go back and forth
and a big shout out also to the players
for their cooperation in coming on the
show and sharing with us their thoughts
so sometimes it's not very easy for us
to get the players to join us as they're
so locked in to their prep and their
combative play and I have to say about
that game between chakri armam and the
yarov and mvl I was quite wrong because
I thought that we're going to see a very
quick draw but let's go to Maurice in
Zagreb Maurice what do you have for us
well thanks Chris I said uh Christian
excuse me uh let me tell you we are
excited here in Zagreb and as I
mentioned Gary walking by the studio
it's great to have this glass partition
and Gary had a wry smile with his
confidante Michael kurukovski you could
see he felt a little bit of energy from
that win
but instantly put his game face back on
and started pacing back and forth yet
again as though he understands one game
does not a day make so you know what a
champion thinks I won one so what put it
behind me short memory on to the next
one someone who is happy to have this
round behind him is Yonder pomachi as he
won a big game take a look at this
position he had against Anton karbov he
had played a very nice opening stole
upon in the end game but right here
there was some compensation that Anton
was trying to cook up but the move Rook
takes D2 he thought I got a tricky
little idea let me see if it works and
he took on B6 in this position hitting
the Rook on C7 hitting the Rook on D2
got the pin on The Rook on on the night
on C6 but suddenly the move Rook cd7
defending both Rooks B7 looks like it
could be good except night back to B8
and Rook CA check is met by Brook back
to d8 he had a sacrifice waiting and
after King takes D2 is a bishop with
this past Pawn on B7 unfortunately
that's not nearly enough because the
king gallops into the game and very
easily stops that pawn and now the Rook
turns into a mad piece Rook down to D2
Rook to A2 and that's all she wrote he
played a few more moves queening and
trying to get through but it was very
easy to shut down the counter play and
nepo won the game so bad news there for
karabov great news for Nepal his half a
point lead has now been extended to a
full point another game
to note the other victory in this round
was with a Geary sorry gristook Judah
and Grisha
and it was here I want to show this
moment later in the game
I got the wrong game up guys sorry about
that Duda versus Grisha here we go this
one
we see Grisha got this great position
and right here after the move Queen to
D6 you see the diagonal Pressure Queen
to H2 check is coming there's nothing
really to do about it because what are
you supposed to do if you play G3 you're
going to lose Knight F1 will be a
sacrifice Knight F3 was hit by Rook
takes on F3 Queen F3 and Rook to f8 with
the idea of Queen H7 made very basic
almost puzzle Rush type tactic happened
in this game the very important game
another important game was Anan versus
Geary Anan had his chances here and
messed up all the way down in a winning
position right around here he had a
great game look at these past pawns
should have won this game but he played
with some errors in this moment played
King to E1 allow this Pawn to drop and
then this move Knight C5 in his Rook is
Tethered to both the Knight and the pawn
on B5 and this shut down a lot of his
Advantage he went on and Geary defended
very well and was managed and managed to
save the draw in this game Gary with
some faint hopes of catching nepo but
the distance between him and nepo right
now is increased
can anyone stop the nepo train yesterday
nepo did win his first game as well but
he lost then Drew then lost he'll try to
erase that sequence and create a new
history we'll see how he goes and let
you know as we continue following the
action here live from Zagreb guys back
to you thank you Maurice and let's go to
our standings after a very eventful
round 10.
leading the pack with 18 points
extending his lead at the top Max invest
your legraff one point behind him with
17 points Anish giri two points behind
the leader with 16 points vishwanathan
with 15 points in fourth position Jan
Christoph Duda 14 and a half points
Alexander Grisham 14 points in sixth
position chakriharma mediarov after a
valiant effort to take down mvl but
unfortunately for him did not manage to
do so with 13 points 13 and a half
points in seventh position Kasparov an
important victory for him now in uh tied
for eighth position with 11 and a half
points quite an interesting and compact
field we have right now absolutely
Christian and our friends at
kasparaofchess.com would like to share
with us a lesson a Trotsky study and
we'll see you on the other side of the
break
foreign
[Music]
we're gonna talk about a study composed
by Trotsky
Trotsky was a great composer from the
USSR
who was very prolific in the early 20th
century
it was specialized for instance in
fortresses and this study is a first
study I've been given for solving
I did fail but I was young and naive
no if we're gonna take a look at the
position
the material is equal
but two factors are very much
in Black's favor
first of all my knight is under attack
meaning I will lose one tempo
and more importantly the d-pawn is
running towards promotion
so clearly white wants to make a draw
now if you want to have a deeper look at
the position I encourage you to pause
the video
so now we can talk about the specifics
of the position Black's King
is a bit unsafe it only has one square
to one from but for now for instance G
Suite check King G5 is not useful
so instead of course we cannot move the
Kink towards the pawn because the Knight
is under attack so we have to move the
Knight
we cannot create a mating thread with a
knight because there's no Square where
it controls the square on G5
so this way
the natural try would be to go Knight D7
D3 and Knight F6 and the point is to get
to E4 where you can attack not only the
pawn on D2 but the square on G5 for
instance D2 no G Suite check Works King
G5 90 for check and you win the pawn on
D2
unfortunately
after Knight F6 Bishop B8 check
is a very strong intermed so now if
white moves the king another D2 and G3
doesn't work anymore
so clearly in Knight D7 was wonk
the other natural move is obviously
Knight C6
now the black Bishop is under attack and
you cannot move it because if I move it
worst case I can take the pawn and
because the H Pawn is I mean because
it's an h-pawn and the bishop is of the
one color it's an immediate draw
so clearly black will move his Pawn
toward promotion which was his plan all
along
and now it's a critical moment of the
study it's how to
to create an attack so one try would be
95.
and after D2 you play F4 so you replace
um the Knight was supposed to control G5
but you cannot do it so now the pawn
control G5 because my knight controls
the square on G4 and I do strategies we
made
I also threaten Knight F3 check with a
fork but unfortunately
Bishop G1 check spoils the party and
after I take no black can Queen
and win the end game effortlessly
so after D3 we need to find another
solution
what kind of solution is there
what we know is that the king is a bit
stuck
but first we need to take the bishop
because the bishop otherwise L helps
black too much to
uh to create his own play so of course
black one is the word promotion
and now is the actual point of the study
so you don't check the black thing yet
you want the king to stay on H4
so you're gonna hit B5 black gets a
queen on D1
and now I go Knight C3 I attack the
queen and very importantly my next move
wants to be Knight E4 after which
the king is stuck forever on H4 because
Knight only four would control G3 and G5
and importantly a knight on info would
be supported by a Pawn on F3 which means
that the Knight cannot be placed under
attack
so after Knight C3 black has only one
way to prove an id4 it's to put the king
each track so Queen D6 check and now I
just move my king to H1
and the point is D6 is really not a
great score for the queen because if if
I go is a king just working G5 that
fails to 90 for check with the fork
and also black has no more check so he
goes for instance let's say queen E5
now Knight E4
and for no Waiters
cannot do anything but he can move his
King from G1 to H1 or H2
and also after let's say queen A1
checking H2 you cannot
both prevent both King G1 and King H1
and like you could do this Queenie one
but no G Suite check wins a queen
because otherwise the king is mated
so black actually has to prevent that
and then there's no way to
an entangle and so it's a positional
draw
[Music]
a most beautiful study indeed thank you
mvl and we are back let's jump right
into it on our second day of Blitz for
the pairings Christian some very
exciting matchups we have mvl versus
Anish giri we have Jana ponyashi versus
shakriaro which will be our Marquee
matchup it will be indeed we have
grishuk versus Gary Kasparov we have
Jordan van Forest against Anton corabov
Jan Christoph Duda versus she or not we
have so many clashes and there you see
it as the players get ready for their
round 11 matchups once again we have
nine rounds of Blitz we've just seen our
first round Gary Kasparov doubling his
point output over yesterday as he's won
his first game and there he is on the
left Jan nepo nepo the Challenger to
Magnus Carlson said he wanted to use
this tournament as his training for his
world championship match Wesley so our
grand chess tour leader says no nepo go
in there and win as many Grand chess
tour points as possible and to deny the
tour players as many points grantchester
points as well and on the right we have
shakuria memedar of the winner of the
first leg of the grand chest tour from
Bucharest Romania he's looking to bounce
back into the field and and again nepo
has been using C4 G3 Bishop G2 is a kind
of universal Panacea against any opening
or defense that black may use and the
players have transposed into what I
expect to be a benoni after D4 D5 and in
their previous encounter in the rapid
portion we've seen mabelier of choose D6
and a king's Indian approach right now
we're seeing him immediately attack the
center with the move C5 allowing this
benoni with D5 but nepo decides to go
Knight to F3 a much more calm approach
and immediately is met with D5
Plastering blasting open in the center
with D5 yes indeed I'm just drawing up
that game and uh I'm the convention has
been whenever you see these move C5
you almost automatically as white knight
F3 is kind of a side variation you
almost automatically see the D5 and a
transposition into a benoni after these
after after D5 it's almost a grown felt
but there's a bishop on G2 which is very
unusual for grunfeld what do you call
this uh Christian what is this position
it's difficult to uh call it in any way
shape or form I believe D5 is so natural
in that position and allowing the benoni
uh for white D5 for white it's whatever
uh black plays the move C5 now that
you're allowing me to play D5 this is
already considered to be very much okay
for black you don't get this type of
Physicians almost never because whenever
you want to get a slav slash groomfeld
to then you're going to play the move C6
first and then you're going to play D5
and even then sometimes C6 to C5 is
considered to be an equalizing move to
get C5 in one move like this D5 and then
C5 without losing anything this is a
victory for uh black in the opening and
I think has to be very happy with the
outcome of it yeah Bishop takes C3
Bishop D2 I'm used to seeing moves like
Rook d8 here and or Bishop E6 after Rook
d8 Bishop takes C3 Queen takes C3 is
with a check so white does not win a
piece does not end up material ahead so
Rook d8 is considered the the way to go
in these types of positions and that was
played by the way with the move Rook d8
I'm very satisfied as black absolutely
yes we're going to see Bishop takes C3
most likely Queen takes C3 as you were
mentioning yes thinking you're going to
play Queen takes C d8 in fact and
sacrifice your queen for Rook bishop and
pawn this is a kind of a reversal of the
old Catalan position but isn't that with
too much of a risky approach in this big
specific tournament situation because
Bishop take C3 Queen takes C3 B take C3
there you go
and he did it uh I think that this is
the right choice for white because it's
yes it's a rook bishop and Ponce so from
the material point of view the queen is
a happy camper on the other hand it's
the quality of this dark Square Bishop
you with the move G7 G6 this bishop is
really good from White's point of view
it's about speed of play I want to play
Rook D1 I want a castle and I want to
double on the D file as quickly as
possible if I can do those things I'll
have an Initiative for the material and
by the way this game has been played
before no kidding yes it has it's all
Theory and it was actually in
1993 by two players that let's say are
not a lead level Grand Masters okay
23.50 yeah for white kaunas quesstutis
maybe you know this blur and uh kakus
sandor with the black pieces
maybe maybe
uh but uh okay uh the position is
actually more double edged than you
might think and over the next two three
moves the player you know
who grabs the initiative
um will likely be a winner I I the
imbalance is in the position are such
that it's it's not a comfortable draw
for either player and I do think that if
I'm white I'm a kind of happy camper I
want to play Rook D1 b2b4 now that the
Knight is on C6
oftentimes the night goes to A6 to try
to tickle the spawn and specifically for
that reason black played the move Queen
to D5 to take control over that C5
square and activate the queen because
you're probably going to have to defend
that pawn on C5 with the move such as B4
but then the queen might land on C4
later on in the game so the queen
doesn't have to stay passive on C7 as it
was during the variations that you were
showing yes right exactly
exactly
now is there some nice way and that's
exactly what we're getting on the board
B4 Queen to C4 Rook to C1
okay so this Pawn is probably
Untouchable after some move like Knight
it takes before Bishop B1 this Pawn on
the other hand
does look tender Queen takes E2 maybe
something with a beef or meat my arrows
are terrible uh Queen takes E2 maybe
something with an A4 B5 Knight D4 y can
get
those Queen side pawns moving he might
get something going but now for me a
very important question like in fact the
most important question is how is white
intending to meet A5
well he hasn't played A5 he played I
believe E5 Bishop F5 remember okay
I think that is a good that's reasonable
very do you believe this is exactly why
he didn't take on E2 because if you take
on E2 after a move such as Knight to D
for exchanging those Knights that Bishop
might get stuck on C8 to the defense of
that B7 point but here's the question
what about E2 E4 oh that's a very good
question yes sir if you play Bishop
takes E4 I've got Knight D2 and that's a
nasty Fork after E4 I suspect the bishop
is just going to move and then white
might say well maybe I shouldn't have
closed my diagonal uh no I think E2 E4
is met by just a simple bishop move we
need to play for B5 in this position and
who's done it A4 he played A4 okay play
day four now we're probably going to see
the move A6 I think it's almost forced
you cannot allow that move B5 not only
that that's going to drive the Knight
back chords but also is going to open
the chance for my knight to jump in the
center to E5 that's very bad news for
blacks so wow
okay that's huge so what happens after
night uh 92 Queen C5 sorry uh clear that
cobwebs good morning St Louis A Brave
decision but I have to say maybe
see your reputation Bishop E1 the that
move much might have worked move ago
will be met by the simple Knight C2 and
maybe A4
was
asking too much from the position was
our tournament leader Napo A4 Knight
takes B4 don't see a refuge refutation
to this move uh Christian I do not see
it either any there's anybody that can
beat nepo with the black pieces that is
shakri yarma mediaro because he invites
this type of complications and he
invites this type of tactical sharp play
every single time he doesn't shy away
almost ever and this is the antidote
he loves the rough and Temple of the of
the Chess World no question about it
Knight B3 tickling the Queen the queen
needs to maintain the defense over the
night on B4 Queen A4 walks into Knight
A5 thanks to this bishop on uh G2 and
the Knight on A5 Queen C4 would be a bad
move the result well that leaves one
square left queen D6 Queen to D6 now
Rook to D1 is going to be met with
Queen to E6 maybe Queen it's a counter
shot against the Knight would be my
guess we have Rook to D1 on the board
and queen to E6 was played okay
I mean these players are playing
it's a high tight rope Act and the onset
never mind let me just get my Bishop he
knows that this dark Square Bishop is a
huge compensation whenever it's on the
long diagonal both Grand Masters
understood that very well Queen E6 not
waiting for the bishop to park itself on
F6 was a quick response quickly at
Christian the time of the two players
the times right now are very close we
have yanipominyashi with 46 seconds and
Mommy diarov with 55 seconds Bishop G5
Bishop E4 on the board
57 to be now precise I was going to say
that for me I don't like the decision of
trading the light Square Bishops by
Yan I think Bishop F1 might have been
by the way big breaking news as we're
being told that mvl who is in second
place coming into this round won his
game
Bishop E7 again
Jan's looking to get his Bishop to an
anchor Square such as D4 D4 being ideal
in fact
controlling the long diagonal and
patrolling the lung diagonal but also
much more importantly nicely defended H5
oh I was about to say any H5 would be
met instantly by H4 hence we saw the
move G5 first as a preparatory move to
H4 Rook D4 what did he put A5
H5 H4 H3 that's a natural mating idea
for Black's point of view I'm not sure I
was a fan of Rook A5 I think he had to
play Rook D4 with the idea of meeting H5
with H4 he's a Tempo behind and now he's
got rookie four and I don't see how nepo
is going to stop the move H4 and that's
simply huge this could be like a boss
right now this could be a winning
position H4 H3 and that's it you can
take my opponent on A7 absolutely oh no
that problem yeah I was about to say
maybe a trade of Rooks just to prevent
this type of activity we're going to say
F6 right now well how about H3 Rook
takes D4 and H3
you start with the move H3 in those
positions the bishop is not moving away
but he didn't defend now Queen to G2
we're going to take this Pawn on HG yes
and he's that H Pawn is huge of course
King to G6 I think this was a very
important move Rook takes B7 Queen hits
The Rook that's with a huge Tempo
Against The Rook check F6 of course
and H2
why didn't he play HTTP to D1 threaten
this check on F3 Queen to F3 and this is
winning H oh he didn't play H2 no that's
a good move that's a good move okay
finally
oh the game beautiful
beautiful play by Shaq as he set up this
beautiful and we also have a game
between Duda Vichy looks like
Duda may have lost no that one ended in
a Perpetual chat oh okay he looked like
he was exhaling like
it was a very tense game but it ended in
a Perpetual track okay could you just
run through the scores for me because I
haven't been able to see any of the
other games yes absolutely so we do have
Duda who made a draw against uh Vision
we have grishuk who defeated Gary
kasprov that Forest who lost against
Anton korob with the white pieces of
Napo miyashi the game that we just saw
lost against mohammediarov and lost the
sole leadership position as well because
mvl is now tied for the leadership
position these guys are jockeying for
that literacy spot every single round
we're seeing exactly the same thing
happening in day two as what happened in
day one of Blitz such an amazing
tournament so far and the last one was
again of course the one between mvl and
Anish giri we did not see that game in
depth but I'm sure we will have Maurice
explaining absolutely everything that
happened in that one later on thank you
for that question and just we'll get in
a commercial message just before we jump
to Zagreb as the Q Boutique here in
Saint Louis is selling some merchandise
they're having a 30 off sale on their
grand Chester swag you can see what are
examples of the new Grand chess tour
merchandise that is now in store please
take a look shop at Q Boutique St
louis.com and show your support for our
grand chess tour
what a way of starting the day yeah I
mean uh I just catching my breath these
games uh and like you said uh Maurice
opened the show talking about the
jockeying for position and we're seeing
exactly a repeat of day one I have to
say I was a little bit afraid that nepo
is just gearing up to run away with the
event but that's not happening but we do
have Maurice in Zagreb Maurice what do
you have for us
well I have that my brain is spinning
from all the craziness that happened in
this last round I was trying to follow
all the other four games simultaneously
and what a wild ride that was let me try
to settle it in one at a time without
screwing up too badly first of all this
one between vashilagrov and Anish giri
the opening win fine for Anisha got a
solid position but he slipped up right
here after the move Rook to B1 he needs
to ignore this pawn bishop B7 is not
quite a threat because of Rook to B8 and
some chances to equalize instead he
defended with Rook to be eight and after
Rook A4 again he's got to play B6 and
just stay solid although he might lose
this a pawn he gets some play instead he
played Rook A6 and Rook to D4 landed on
the board with a thud suddenly Rook
dates coming you can't move the bishop
off of C8 because B7 is hanging this
time with a full Tempo in fact he did do
that but the move Rook d8 is going to be
so strong that he's going to paralyze
his entire position he had to play
Bishop East six Rook takes takes and
takes Rook to B6 followed by a nice
check and a trade of Rooks going into
this far superior ending he wins back
upon temporarily but oops you're going
to gift this Pawn on C5 this is what
happened he took the pawn and we could
jump much later as he gets down to this
position where he's just up heavy
material and was easily able to convert
this into a win big win for maxim
vashilagrav another big game I was so
impressed by this game between van
Forrest and Anton karbov it's at this
point in the game right here
that corball played Knight H4 takes
takes Knight F5 and here he played G6 97
and calmly took just said I'm stacking
an exchange I don't even care I'm just
taking no big deal I'm not letting you
take the pawn on D5 and after Rook to
ac7 he said boom give me the pawn on H3
you can't take back because of Queen G5
check hitting the king and of course the
Rook on E7 and the game was still fine
after Bishop takes H3 Rook takes on B7
for a while until the H Pawn you see
that extra H Pawn it started racing down
the board age four rookie seven H3
rookie one and look at this Sweet
Sacrifice Bishop takes on F2 with check
you don't dare take it back because H2
check you either lose your queen with
King H1 Queen takes queen or you take
the piece and
H2 King F1 and queens and that would be
all she wrote as well so after Bishop F2
he had to stumble with King H1 but H
takes on G2 and nobody can take back
it's going to be mate some kind of way
King takes of course leads to Queen G3
check and Bishop F3 look at those two
killer bees that exchange sock worked
out perfectly for Anton great great game
the game gristook versus Kasparov Gary
play like a boss in the beginning I
loved the way he played he played
aggressively this is the position from a
grinfo when he played F5 Dynamic
weakening to be short but aggressive
after King h8 castles fjc4 Knight G5 he
said you can have the exchange I don't
care about that maybe slightly worse for
black but definite compensation Gary
with the good position Rook to E1 he
just has to develop his Bishop somewhere
D7 or F5 just bring the piece into the
game instead he said I smell a tactic
and he played Bishop takes on H3
this was problematic however he was
expecting maybe this line where he can
pressure the position with a vicious
typical Gary Casper of attack no can do
grishek said wait a minute this
sacrifice is not sound I take on D4 and
I'm not taking on this square and allow
you Queen G3 check no no that's not
going to happen what's going to happen
however is Rook takes E4 now the bishop
on D4 is hanging the bishop on H3 is
also hanging and that was all she wrote
you can't take this because if Queen
takes A1 and if Queen is sick we trade
and gift me the bishop Gary lost a piece
in this way and that was that and the
sad game folks the sad one if I may
finish up is this one with Duda and Anan
we get all the way to this position here
this position Anan is got an exposed
King it's about to be prepared you've
got to be careful and here he missed
mate with Rook G1 check that would have
been devastating a beautiful way to
finish off the game because King takes
is made by Queen D1 check give me this
with check
another check forcing you up give me
that with check and he would have just
been playing checkers in this game this
was over if you had found Rook G1 check
other lines lead to mate as well instead
he missed it in time pressure played
Rook V4 and a lot of her pet poor
unknown two games he was winning and he
let these youngsters off the hook he
must be feeling frustrated he could have
had two full points and now only one
from two draws that was a crazy round
guys I hope I recapped it in the short
enough time but a brilliant brilliant
round lots of aggression lots of wins
let's hope we can see more of this we'll
be covering the action here trying to
keep the heart under control guys thank
you Maurice keeping our hearts in the
control indeed that just take a look at
our standings as we jump to our lesson
here we are at the top it's MBL and Jan
nepo tied for first but it look at that
Blitz score eight points for nvl so
seven points for Ian as mvl is showing
his class in Blitz and now let's quickly
go to a lesson from our friends at
kasparovchess.com it's fighting against
the sidelines and we're going to see on
the other side of the break
[Music]
[Music]
the French is the opening you can play
against the move a one E4 with the move
one E6
this is not the most topical opening but
it has been played by some great players
of the past most notably Michael
botwinick and Victor course Noy also
Armenian players symbato Bhutan
and verafal baganyan have done a great
contribution and many many others Arthur
yusupov is a notable example and also
the players the modern players have
played it occasionally Magnus Carlsen
plays the French also many many others
the German youth players uh the top
youth players are playing it
the point of the opening is to fight for
the center while we don't immediately
control these squares we intend to push
the Deep on to D5 and hit the E4 Pawn
now the problem is quite evident after
G4 D5
we have the issue with of the C8 Bishop
it is potentially a belt Bishop
but things are not so simple let's look
at options white has here
after he takes D5 the so-called exchange
range blackplayers it takes D5 and the
bishop gets activated position is
symmetric and pretty equal
other options provide the advanced
French the move E5 very critical move
white controls the center but black
starts the counter play against the D4
Pawn with the move C5
after C3 the main line continues with
Knight C6
Knight F3 and now Queen B6
this is the main line hitting the D4
Pawn keeping an eye on the B2 Pawn black
has quite some counter play here
another big variation is the tires
defense move Knight D2
here black has an option of playing
Knight F6 provoking the move E5
or the main move C5 challenging the
center and opening up the position
after for example it takes D5
Queen takes D5
DTX C5 black can recapture the C5 Pawn
with the queen or with the bishop and we
get the standard structure for this
variation a very complicated structure
but essentially a fine for black
the main variation is the third move
Knight C3
here black has three options
dtx4 is a so-called Rubenstein French
the positions after Knight X E4 are
relatively simple black is trying to get
this 97 Knight gf6 then the C5 break
trade these two pawns and get a position
similar to the tarash variation
this is a very solid weapon black does
not get many winning chances but it's
been played most notably by yorkmeyer
from Germany uh quite a lot of games he
played it throughout his career and he
claims this is a decent weight a decent
way of fighting for the quality
but the two most popular lines are much
more strategically complex
Knight F6
this is the classical variation quite
remarkably it's been played by casparov
and kramnik after their retirement I
don't know what to think about it but
that's that is a fact that's Knight F6 a
white pushes the pawn to E5 immediately
or after the move Bishop G5
the position after E5 Knight comes to
the seven white usually plays F4 black
plays C5 white usually plays Knight F3
now we get this very complicated
position the C8 Bishop is a problem very
often it trades itself via A6 to the F1
bishop or sometimes the bishop remains
here and black stars counter play
against the D4 Pawn with moves like
Knight C6 Queen B6 or breaks the E5 Pawn
with the move F6
its positions are very complex but the
other options black has against the
third move Knight C3
is even more complicated that is the
bishop before leaving our variation
the positions become very balanced here
after the move E5 we plays C5 the main
line goes with A3 Bishop xc3 BC
and this is one of the most
strategically complex positions in chess
white has advantage of two Bishops and a
very strong central control a complete
control over the E5 Square as he has the
dark Square Bishop black in his turn has
a better Pawn structure white already
got weaknesses here and if black manages
to trade the bishop he's going to have a
positional advantage
the main line continues even more
fascinatingly with move 97
white plays Queen G4 and black can
sacrifice the G7 Pawn with the move
Queen C7
Queen takes G7 Rook G8 Queen takes H7
black is currently two points down but
he hits back in the center with C takes
D4
and this is a very complicated position
the winner defends the tibia of the
vinegar defense many uh top level games
have uh played been played here I played
it with the white pieces against Magnus
Carlsen this is also incidentally my
youth weapon I played this as a child
with black a very complicated once again
the French defense very strategically
complex sound but a compact defense for
black as we saw there are not that many
deviations for it so it is a perfect
choice on uh to play on all the levels
starting from amateurs all the way to
the top level
foreign
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the grand chest tour
from Zagreb at Croatia as we get ready
for round 12. let's first take a look at
our current standings and then we're
going to go into our pairings we have
Maxim vashir lagrav catching up with Jan
Nepal Nishi at the top of the standings
tied for first position with 18 points
Anish giri in third position with 16
points two points behind with seven
rounds to go with what we have
vishwanathan with 15 and a half points
in fourth position tied for fifth
position Alexander grishuk and Jan
Christoph Duda we have Shakira mediarov
Anton karobov Kasparov and Jordan van
forest in the final form rishik also
showing his Blitz skills with seven uh
in the blitz score as you can see he's
tied with Jan for uh showing great Blitz
understanding and round 12 pairing set
the table for us please Christian we
have our Marquee matchup of the
the tiger of Madras the five-time world
champion facing Maxim vashier La grav on
board one then we have Anish giri versus
Jan napomiyashi a great matchup probably
our Reserve matchup yeah then we have
that Anton korob against Grisha we have
shakuri armamediarov versus Jordan van
forest and Gary Kasparov versus Jan
Cristo Duda a clash of generation as
Maurice was just informing as Bishi and
Nan uh two draws but
letting the youngsters Escape as he
missed that beautiful move Rook G1 check
that would have brought him victory
I mean he's playing really well I mean
welcome to Rapid and Blitz Vichy has
always been a great natural rapid and
Blitz player and uh just missing
I want to say apply here and there if he
had found a couple of key moves uh who
knows he might be contesting for a
Podium finish and there he is five-time
world champion and I remember a dinner
where I had set a five-time world
champion and he kind of whispered to me
afterwards you know I won nine World
Championships right and he wasn't
informing me about his Blitz as well as
rapid world championship titles that
he'd also won and I said yeah that's it
that sounds like too many of issues
quite quite this is a man on his game
for the past three decades he's just
simply amazing yeah but hasn't played
chess over the board chess I mean in
what did he say 14 months I think for 16
months I think he mentioned and it's all
about the filling right the feeling that
you're almost forgetting whenever you
have such a long period of inactivity 16
months you're not used to that traveling
you're not used to that seeing your uh
peers you're not used to being away from
your family so your priorities change
big time and just to remind our viewers
once again mvl has outscored everybody
in the blitz so far so we'll see what
vishy can do with his open Sicilian
again he played this his entire career
is a natural one E2 E4 player but he did
win the world championship match against
kramnik by changing uh to D4 such a
versatile versatile
uh player is vishyanan and now we have a
Dragon dwarf kind of a mixture a hybrid
if you will of both the Knight ORF and
the dragon the move a284 invited the
dragon and
that was exactly what mvl did move Rook
B8
uh
prepping something based on Knight takes
D4 and B5 because the pawn on e4 is
vulnerable but
I'm kind of confused by the move Rook B8
no that is definitely its main objective
in that position to get off this a file
and try to prepare P5 at one point or
the other and this Dragon dwarf is
possible we are seeing this G6 in the
neither especially when white is sort of
losing its opportunity to Long castle
with a move A4 at move number six what
we've seen in this game you're not going
to go long Castle so we're only going to
see short Castle from White and that is
very important because that's when black
wants to play G6 whenever I was playing
the dragon myself I was so happy
whenever I was seeing this quiet systems
with Bishop to E2 short Castle I knew
that I'm very close to equalizing and
this is exactly what we're seeing from
mvl he is not a dragon player but he
knows that in certain nuances in the
neither of he can transition into a
dragon and he feels very comfortable
doing so
okay cool uh the bishop E2 I've kind of
thought of these as the Nottingham
variation from Nottingham England
and white often times uh plays with a
dollop of poison based on the Move F2 F4
now in this case Vichy has parted with
his light squared Bishop in order to
dominate over the B6 Square Vichy is one
of those players one of those very rare
players at the elite level who's more
than willing to trade off his two
Bishops for a night and he has
proven over the many decades of the
rightness of his perspective as he's
scored very well here he has one of
those typical positions where it is a
case of a knight versus Bishop but
usually you do want to take away the two
bishops from your opponent so I see this
move F2 F3 as a move that preps Bishop
H6 and I was dead wrong he just played
Queen F2 like no problem I want to keep
the dark Square Bishop what's the idea
behind the move Queen F2 uh Christian I
believe it's preparing the move Bishop
to D4 in the future also maybe if you're
going to try to double up on the C file
I have some ideas with Rook to D4 and
trapping that Queen there on C4 I am not
100 sure it's a very uh intriguing move
I have to say Bishop H6 seemed much more
natural in that variation and probably
would have been the option for many of
us just exchanging that dark Square
Bishop we know that that is one of the
best weapons in Black's Arsenal
absolutely in these positions when the
Knight on D4 has stepped back to B3 it
loses its control over the E6 square and
is very common for for black to move his
Bishop to E6 not 100 sure I'm a big fan
of the queen being on C4 maybe Queen B4
with the idea of Rook take C3 a very
standard exchange sacrifice yeah I was
about to say the queen on C4 doesn't
feel right he steps back with Queen C7
does mvl and as you said Queen F2 preps
Bishop D4 in this particular case maybe
bishop takes F6 and Knight D5 could be
considered as a threat but again C2 is
hanging I do have fun at least I do have
to say that Queen on F2 doesn't make a
very good impression on me I'm still
trying to wrap my head around exactly
why F2 is better on that D2 because you
could have put that Bishop on D4 with a
queen on D2 as well there's absolutely
no drawback to that and now we see
perhaps what vishi had in mind nice
again okay
is potentially is is looking for a
knight to C4 to B6 maneuver and or a
maneuver like Knight F1 to E3 and again
looking at control over the D5 Square so
Queen F2 uh a Prelude to Knight to D2
well also this is why these players are
so strong they see a position they
immediately Target and understand which
piece stands the worst that was in our
case the Knight on B3 it wasn't doing
anything at that position so immediately
finds a way to reshuffle it to a much
more active square and that is as you
were mentioning Yasser probably Knight
to C4 you do have to be a bit careful
with Knight C4 because Bishop 4 might
come into play nevertheless I do think
that Knight C4 Knight to B6 is the
landing Square because that's going to
take away that beautiful Square on a
semi-open file from the rookon C8 also
the knight from B6 is potentially going
to uh watch that square D5 and
potentially land on it well now that the
pawn is on A5 there's no B7 B5 uh brakes
for black in the position so black is
going to have to rely upon e65 and or E5
D5 it's very hard to get in both E5 as
well as D5 because any E5 move is going
to precipitate Bishop to B6 which
controls d8 and doesn't let you play for
D5 so the IC Vichy strategy as being one
of restraint that basically what vishy
is going to say is I put my Pawn on A5
so you have no Queen side brakes I'm
gonna put my knight on E3 so you're
going to have no Central breaks you
don't want to play D5 with the Knight on
E3 I could play E5 and F4 you don't want
to play E5 and D5 because E5 will give
up control over the D5 Square so
restraint in the words of Aaron Nims of
its restraint blockade destroy and by
the way Knight on E3 might look like a
cir
it takes a long time to get the Knight
to B6 but without the move Bishop B5 one
day Knight C4 and 96 lands with Tempo
Queen H4 hitting the Knight we do see
this trade of the bishop
we could have done this a long time ago
with Bishop H6 so uh but no harm no foul
I mean uh it's taken Vichy a while to
get his pieces to the squares he wants
but he's getting them there uh Rook D4
Queen D2 King H1 Knight G4 these are all
moves that I'd have on my agenda is
white and I say I I'm I've got the game
under control so again I'm looking at
Rook D4 oh he took and played Just C3
that I'm thinking that the trade kind of
relieves
uh lack a bit uh those I'm not sure I
like this nice C3 takes B5 trade by
vishi but he did double up the pawns I
have to agree with you on that when he
asked her because specifically that pawn
on A5 becomes a bit of a Target now Rick
to uh from C8 to A8 potentially be a
move and then if white is forced to play
the move uh B for defending that pawn on
A5 then that pawn on C3 is just going to
be a weakness forever and to be honest
that Knight on C3 was almost acting as a
plug on the C5 exactly it was just it
was completely killing uh Black's play
on that file that [ __ ] Pawn B5 wasn't
doing much no exactly the bishop B5
wasn't bothering anyway this trade is a
bit intriguing and mysterious to me okay
Queen to C5 I think there's a I think
there's supposed to be a black queen on
C5
sometimes on these uh dgz boards when
when you do play quickly the piece
doesn't land maybe the bird eye view so
that we squarely on nowhere the queen is
yeah so Queen C5 not Queen E3 Ah that's
what happened the the queen E3 Queen D4
got registered how it so we think that
there's a black queen on C5 maybe we can
see the bird eye view of uh the position
of the rule now hard to see from there
we go and there we do we do have Queen
takes
so there was an exchange so we go back
to this position and we believe it was
Queen takes C5
D takes C5 Knight to E3 Knight to D3 I
think we have an up-to-date position
well I have to say the past five moves
have been definitely favorable for uh
black that Knight on D3 looks beautiful
I think okay my board is Frozen at the
moment we're just going to watch the
bird's eye view I think exactly we're
going to see B4 right now defending that
pawn on A5 you cannot take Ampersand
because that Knight on D3 is just going
to fall wait a minute can you take
Ampersand that's the question and he's
stopping to think about it and now vishi
is thinking as well I don't think you
can because you have nothing nice
B2 Rook D1 Rook takes A5 Knight to C2
and that stops in your tracks B7 B6 and
uh
Vichy says okay
you've got a great night on
D3 and I've got to get rid of it
I think that's exactly what he's done
now uh black I think is for choices he's
gets in this very important move Rook A3
seizing the initiative and I think Vichy
has to get his Rook initiative as well
with Rook to D7 with the intention of
Rook B7 we've played it now now if the
Rook doubles on the seventh King H1 and
Rook G1 will be vichy's answer King H2
uh I didn't like King H2 because of that
move Rook takes F3 I think the King on
H1 would not have made Rook F3 possible
and we can see a cup by vishwanathan he
realizes that that pawn was not supposed
to be lost exactly he stopped him in his
tracks he could have played King H1
and he would have had a very very easy
time of it now he's
he's fighting for a draw frankly Rook
takes C3 283 seconds for mvl 48 seconds
Rook G2 now it's all about Rook takes F7
check
he can and he's done it King H6 and you
can go back Rook G1 and I think that
might have been the Saving Grace was
Vichy yes exactly fortunate enough but
it is not over yet nope mvl still for
choice
as he is
um well one one Pawn up one Pawn up
that's an important move
h5h4 it basically locks in
Black's King and it keeps this Rook on
G1
oh C3 really if that was necessary now I
think it's just a draw it is not that
easy I think it's a G4 is an important
move because now The Rook on G1 can be
released for active duties
but that's where she wants to play King
H1 and G3 I I yes sir that that E Pawn
is still it exists I I don't I don't I
don't disagree I mean leaves The Outpost
on G4 decides to activate via the C file
that's a very surprising decision where
she is thinking that his Rook on G1 I
thought the Rook on G4 would be
better suited uh more active Defender
but fishy has a different perspective
that okay now he can just trade Rooks
and that's an easy
wow he decides not yeah
okay he must know something that we
don't yes sir exactly because past pawns
must be pushed I really thought that it
was much better to exchange one pair of
groups but uh for me there was no
question about it E3 he did not choose
to play E3 could have gotten his Pawn
by the way breaking news as nepo has
lost his game against Anish giri who
lives on one point behind him right
Anish was a
situation in G3 oh my goodness she is
really giving his opponent fantastic
opportunity 20 seconds for fishy 10
seconds for mvl I'm afraid that
something like G4 might be winning and
he's going for it yeah I'm afraid that
this could be a winning and you go Rook
to F2
no I wrote that I thought he was going
to go Rook to F2
why didn't he go Rook to F2 now we're
going to see a company the idea of G4
was to keep the king so that it's
protected you could go on Rook F2
F4 came to F4 okay maybe the crisis has
suddenly passed as once again vishy can
go check and get into a single Rook
ending that let's get a roof off the
board no fishy says again keeping four
Rooks on the board in my view oh
rook and wait a minute isn't that big G2
what was that seriously wait a minute
that's check check again
and no we don't have anything really
what whoa somebody's playing for a win
is vishy really playing for a win no no
no no no no no there's there's nobody's
playing for it okay wow sorry about that
that my uh board got frozen but uh
okay we really had a mix at the end and
for Vish he dodged a bullet a little bit
there no absolutely he did but he was uh
not he was playing very courageous I
have to say uh it didn't feel like he
was in trouble at least emotionally at
any point in the game and that is one of
his biggest strengths he's so stoic he
just looks like nothing will affect him
uh in this tournament he defended that
four Rook end game brilliantly I have to
say just not exchanging maybe not
exchanging that Rook was the right play
because those Rooks were always creating
threats against the black king it felt
like it at least with the specific time
situation on the clock we remember mvl
was actually down on time so maybe that
is why the Practical Choice was to keep
four Rooks on the board but we do have
Maurice with some news about this
amazing Rod Maurice
another incredible round victories just
flying all over the place one game to
note is Gary kasparov's game uh he had a
fantastic position coming in the middle
game played beautiful chess and then in
time pressure that Bugaboo that has been
haunting him throughout
he just made some mistakes that led to a
bad position in the end it looked like
he lost on time the position he had on
the board was lost anyway so he's got to
get that speed up that natural pace but
definitely playing better than he was
yesterday but the big game of the round
we're going to focus on is a couple of
the other victories you can check out
Geary versus nepo nepo with the black
pieces remember yesterday he won his
first game as he did today he lost his
second game as he did today
yesterday he drew and then lost this
time he forced himself into a lost
position he could have had the same
results as well take a look he had the
black pieces here White's King is being
flushed out and it is a prepet Gary's
ready to accept the draw no problem just
check check no problem but then nepo
said no I'm going to try to win this
game with a check and then another check
and a disaster as the white king raised
up the board and suddenly was away from
any danger Rook C4 check E4 and he built
himself a cage the problem is you can't
steal a rook because Queen F6 check is
simply mate on the next move and so that
was just devastating the move E4 Rook
takes Queen takes and now after Queen D1
check Queen A8 and once again the king
is caged as the queen is going to March
to the G7 square with no problem and
Checkmate the black king a disastrous
loss because nepo got ambitious overly
ambitious in this this position and so
now suddenly it's the rise of the
Frenchman Maxim vashilagrove who is
showing his incredible Blitz abilities
uh without having to worry about
anything as he watches nepo fade have a
point lead I think it is right now I
should note korabov beat gristook a game
he should not have won but Grisha messed
up also in time pressure and Shakir
marmadirov did a good job from basically
equal position out playing Jurgen van
Forest we're seeing a lot of Victories
folks uh this day this last day is
absolutely insane guys thank you Maurice
Gary casparo's favorite number is the
number 13 born April 13th he was the
13th world champion as we get set for
round 13 guess what we have in store for
you we have a game between Gary Kasparov
versus the swanathon To None they may
not be in first that's going to be our
Marquee match-up game for sure for this
the 13th round but first let's take a
look at the standings where after 12
rounds of play Christian well we have
Maxim vashir lagrap as the new leader of
the competition with 18 and a half
points I believe this might be actually
his first solid of the tournament
with 18 points in second position he
must be feeling quite sad about his
performance today we have Anish giri who
is has won a crucial game against uh
janepo miyashi and is now only a point
and a half behind Maxima visual we're
going to see him in the next round with
16 points Christoph Duda with 16 points
as well mediarov and Alexander grishup
on 15 points Anton corabov 13 and a half
Kasparov slash sarich with 11 points and
a half and Jordan van forest in 10th
position with nine points and our
pairings for this 13th round are really
really mouth-watering as the two
tournament leaders go head to head and
it's amazing that that's not going to be
our Marquee matchup Christian and uh
that is not our Marky matchup because we
have the big clash between former world
champions Gary Kasparov and vishwanathan
Anan and that is going to be our Marquee
matchup of the round then of course we
have yanepo miyashi versus mvl we have
Grisha versus mamadiar of we have Jordan
van Forest versus Anish giri once again
a reiteration of their Ty break match in
the tattoo steel and Duda versus korob
but we do have Maurice in Zagreb with a
special guest Michael korsakowski
Maurice
yes indeed we're with the big MK the Big
Kahuna for the grantchester or Mike
thanks for joining us you must be
pleased with seeing more chess happening
over the board it's been a tremendous
success for the tour so far with these
three events absolutely Maurice it's a
very good event for us a lot of
viewership especially with Gary's
participation although he is not in good
form but anyway viewers uh watching the
games and they understand that this is
not online games it's in person and
players also hungry to play over the
board we can feel a tingling with
excitement but we know you have even
more exciting news about next year's
tour Yes actually we already set up
schedule for season 2022 and I'm happy
to announce that we will have new
spot a new leg in Warsaw Poland another
European Capital joining the tour
incredible so tell us all the events
that will happen will be all five events
that happen this year and next year in
Poland as well in Warsaw well actually
uh next year it will be very heavy
schedule very heavy calendar
for because there will be three grand
prix either events our qualifiers for
the candidate story
than candidate story then World Team
Championships then World Olympiad so
therefore we really need to squeeze
everything in in order not to have a
conflict so we're working with feeding
collaboration in order to make balanced
calendar and actually we succeeded we
will have uh like this here
five events in the regular season
starting in book areas with classical
event going to Paris then going to
Zagreb and then new spot as I mentioned
it would be worser Warsaw will
substitute
Saint Louis rapid and bleeds just for
one year because of this heavy calendar
but
sinful cup as a classical event Remains
the Same as around Rex's birthday as a
matter of fact that exact same feel the
namesake of that event we'll close it
out I will say this is a great schedule
I'm sure polish fans are jumping up and
down yank yourself Judah probably knows
he's already a wild card in that event
uh you're expanding you said only but
you only stayed at five because of the
busy schedule for for next year fida's
busy schedule but that is less busy in
the following year are you planning to
expand the grand chess tour in 2023 well
first of all we will in 2023 we will
reinstate St Louis rapid and bleeds but
we have some other spots on the pipeline
so very possible that we will bring
another capital in Europe
like another tour not to mention that
we're still contemplating to have a
finals so but it must be seen and it
will be announced after single cup I
guess I better start packing my bags now
incredible tour well thank you so much
for that announcement again I'm sure the
Polish fans are thrilled congratulations
on a successful tour so far and we'll
see you in St Louis for the St Louis
rapid employees absolutely looking
forward to that and uh to conclude I
want to appreciate uh all sponsors that
support ground chess tour obviously it's
included chess club Superbad vivendi and
looking forward for the next lick
absolutely thank you so much for joining
us Michael thanks back to you and to see
you thank you Maurice and thank you
Michael for those announcements and
hello Warsaw this is marvelous to have a
tournament in Poland uh your quick
knee-jerk thoughts Christian about out
the next year's Grand Chester well I
have to say Poland and the Polish trans
Federation and chess in Poland as a
whole has been as at the Forefront of
the Revolution the recent Revolution
interest in the past few years they've
been organizing events they've been
finding sponsors all over the place
online there's so many polish fans
there's so many polish streamers as well
we have an avalanche of Polish chess
fans and of course we have one Jan
Christoph Duda who is leading that
revolution in terms of chess players
he's just an amazing chess player he's
going to be their leading Grandmaster
for the years to come and uh yeah it's
so amazing to see another Capital being
added to the Grand Chester gotta love it
2022 promises to be a chess player's
Delight let's take a look at our
predictions I personally am very very
proud of myself I couldn't have been
more or wrong
but you two are really fighting it out
Christian how do you feel about your
picks well I really like the last round
what can I say my big uh betting
Maurice's pick I'm getting closer to uh
mvl but still I mean a long way to go
for me one and a half Point behind mvl I
have to say right now it is Maurice who
is looking quite good and Maurice your
thoughts
I know those words came out of
Christian's mouth which like choking on
them you know you know he hates
admitting when I'm right we'll see
that's around continues there's still
lots of games left no need to brag early
we'll see as MBL is making a case or
maybe being the one who wins the
tournament which I didn't anticipate I
anticipated in Upper winning but right
now
the Frenchman showing his skills in
Blitz which he is absolutely
extraordinary at Blitz and why is that
so important as we see our current
standings mvl surging eight and a half
points is The Blitz score as he leads
the tables on those last two columns but
this event Christian is what mvl needs
to get back into the grantchester
standings he didn't do well in the first
two legs of the grand chest door he
needed a huge event here he's he's
delivering no absolutely he is
delivering and he has been off form in
classical chess in Rapid chess in Bliss
chest for the past year and a half but
right now we're starting to see the
Resurgence of uh mvl and I was looking
on one of the websites that is showing
the live ratings and mvl in this
tournament in the blitz portion he has
won 35 rating points that is huge and
that proposed him back into the top five
right now I think he is live rating uh
is in position number four if I'm not
mistaken and Maurice uh you quick
thought way in here as we get ready for
round 13.
well think about the grand chess tour
standings that's really what's key here
and mvl's position if he wins it's
actually maybe not that significant I
mean of course he comes within range of
Wesley so he actually I believe
overtakes Wesley so but by a smidgen but
those will be his third event he will be
at 22 points if he gets 13 right now the
22 but that will be his third event
Wesley was the left two events left
Wesley would have to fully bomb in order
to lose his this lead over mvl but it's
Anish Geary sitting at five and a half
he needs points he wants to get either
the 13 points for winning this event
which puts him at 18.5 very close to
Wesley or at least 10 which puts him at
15.5 and has a fighting chance to catch
Wesley so so keep an eye underneath
she's going to be fully motivated in the
next few rounds and how ironic that in
this 13th round Ani should go up against
his rival and countrymen Jordan then
Forest where the two famously played a
tie break in this year's atata steel
chess tournament again our Marquee
matchup though is with these two legends
they may have a little wear and tear on
them over the years but boy did they
cross swords uh in their careers uh
marvelous to see these two great great
warriors at the board is they kind of
look at each other and no handshake just
let's go all right let's go says Gary D4
906 E6
and a nimso will we see Queen C2 no
Knight F3
and we've transposed to a rigos and
remember Gary lost catastrophically with
the move Bishop F4 against nepo he's
repeating 97 and Knight E4 was the
prescription that nepo used not Vichy C7
C6 way in here Christian this is the
more topical uh is it C7 to C6 of course
and then probably Knight to D7 is going
to land no matter what but Knight to D7
was opening up the opportunity for uh
other ideas for back such as Queen to B3
and I believe this is exactly what Gary
Castro went back home analyzed a little
bit understood what he has to do and he
was get he was ready to face that Knight
to D7 but C6 is much more of a topical
approach right now if you go Queen to B3
for example without the Knight on D7 I
have the nice Retreat to D6 with my
bishop and that's just going to propose
the exchange of of the bishop so of
course we might not see that let's wait
we see a G6 on the board right now Queen
to C2 G6 preparing the move Bishop to F5
but that leaves a lot of dark squares
around the king's side certainly does
that that is a suspicious move for me
but then again
I have to say that Vichy is such a
wonderfully prepared opening player
doubtlessly he's analyzed this position
in G6 Bishop F5 developing with the
tempo well you can certainly understand
why Vichy uh played the move G7 G6
supporting this bishop now as you were
mentioning the queen excuse me the queen
can go to the B3 Square Queen to B3 then
the bishop
can't drop back to D6 as the pawn on B7
is hanging so after Queen B3 what do you
reckon Vichy has intended well I don't
believe that we're going to see after
Queen to B3 either an immediate exchange
with Bishop takes C3 or we're going to
see a move such as Queen to A5
Queen to be asking the question are you
going to play A3 and try to really kick
that a bishop away then I'm going to
take on C3 you're not going to be able
to take with the queen because I believe
the end game is quite okay for a black
but let's wait and see because right now
after Queen 2b3 which is not actually is
not he played it he played it he played
it
immediately defending the bishop but
your queen A5 by the way I think a2a3
would have chased down the bishop yes
absolutely but he did play the move
Queen B6 and what 934 Bishop to E6 now
that is a very surprising move for me
Knight H4 but he he wanted to chase the
bishop away so that he could follow it
up with Bishop D3 it's custom a Tempo or
two it looks
castles Queen's Gambit
declined now we're seeing a move such as
night age five night Asia okay I'm
puzzled an interesting mix of moves uh
we have that wonderful expression night
on the rim is dim the players are making
an except mockery of our uh deeply held
precepts uh Knight on H4 Knight on H5 if
Bishop H6 I imagine that Vichy wants to
play the move Bishop f8 offering a trade
of Queens as well as a trade of Bishops
an intriguing decision if white tries to
move like Bishop E5
F6 Knight takes I don't think those
sacrifices are going to work so Bishop
E5 F6 Bishop G3 might be about by the
way very very bad clock management by
Gary I'm sorry to say Gary you're
playing Blitz chess that means you only
have five minutes and you're not allowed
to take a one-minute thought uh thing
this this early in the game Christian
you are very correct about that one
right now Garrick hasprov reaching that
two minute uh point and the vishwas with
four minutes and 14 seconds that's a
huge time difference that's two minutes
time difference and let's not forget in
their first encounter yesterday Gary
Casper have lost some time
that was the question also yeah because
I didn't know if he resigned the game he
lost on time because I didn't I I didn't
like that Gary resigned a number of
positions again in Blitz you're supposed
to say I'm thinking after Knight H5 yes
sir he's still thinking no you play
Bishop E5 castles so I guess our board
is not updating yet yeah castles is on
the board I had expected F7 F6 uh Vichy
said I don't have to play F7 F6 I can
castle and I can maybe track this bishop
down with the move Knight D7 followed by
Knight takes E5 and again I'm looking at
Gary's clock and I'm going Gary you
can't do this okay
down to his last minute no way
h2h3 in order to maintain his Bishop
Knight D7 Bishop
H2 but Gary would have been playing
losing a lot of Temple or G4 giving up a
pawn for compensation on the G file you
cannot well you can take but you might
get checkmated after a move such as
route to G1 I'm taking he took it I
don't believe it I think it's more Bluff
and Bluster uh after all where is White
going to put his King white has a king
as well
Rook to G1 Bishop back to E6 and now in
the words of anybody who lives in
Missouri
show me what you got what do you got
vishi has three minutes and 50 seconds
Gary has less than a minute right now
what do you have for the sacrifice Bond
Gary again you know he quaint is the one
sacrificing material he should be the
one uh snapping his moves out F4 F5 is
on his agenda but is he what is he
thinking about castles first he played
Queen C2 okay he's he's ready to
sacrifice more material against the G6
Pawn
and again what Christians Christian
Christian
said what Maurice killed me with this
Christian Christian he started off with
Christians said he's been watching maybe
too many denmarks
I think I think he's ready for the U.S
seniors with Larry Larry Christensen the
big dog comes into town Larry
Christensen
but let's see their lifetime uh Records
in classical chess
17 wins four losses a classical
definitely Gary has the huge upper hand
but I was about to say in Rapid I would
have imagined the story must be the
storyline would have changed a great
deal now Queen C2 I like this move too
by Gary
as he he's the one sacrificing material
so he's trying to keep pieces on the
board specifically the Queens in this
case but he does have ideas he does have
ideas of f4 and a castles followed by F5
I don't believe it's full compensation
but in Blitz the the idea is to put as
many problems to your opponent in as
quick amount of time as you can and you
can see Vichy
which immediately was played on the
board and now we have fire on the board
because wait a minute what is that how
are you going to Define are you going to
take with the F Pawn and then allow
Knight takes G6 and then try to run with
the king is that what it is I don't know
if Rook takes G6 isn't his plan follow I
believe that is his plan so if you take
F7 takes G6 Rook takes G6 check King F7
Rook takes E6 he he took nice I believe
Queen takes
right now I'm imagining the only move in
the position must be rooked to a King to
F7 getting the king off the G file
I don't see anything everybody's getting
very very nervous as this is a very
tense moment uh Vichy played Knight
takes E5 as they're approaching their
last few seconds I think we should move
to the bird's eye view so that we what a
move Knight takes E5 wow I mean you have
to have ice in your veins to play a move
like Knight takes E5 Queen C7 defending
H7 yep Vichy says show me Gary I still
don't think it's enough down to his last
20 seconds Gary Kasparov is one minute
and 20 seconds for visionado
how many seconds I'm sorry
well right now we have 15 seconds 15
seconds for Gary one minute and finally
seconds for this hassles long how long
did it take him to to put his King
in safety
castles long now this night on
H5 is just not doing it for me but it
cannot Retreat to G7 because you're
going to lose that pawn on H that's why
I have to start with Bishop F5 he must
be thinking Bishop F5 and he's done this
but same move faster was better
now he just put a crucial decision to
Vichy and Vichy answered it nicely I
like this move a7a5 I was also thinking
look you know take away
the aggressive pieces fishy getting
nervous
Sands right there we've seen Vichy show
some nerves what happened uh oh what
happened three seconds two seconds one
second gone it's over that's it he
flagged what was that I don't know what
it was the game is over guys yeah the
game is over Gary what was that
by the way let's jump to our our two our
game with our two leaders it's the nepo
versus mvl matchup
well one liter and one chasing that is
true
and I have to say this must be close to
equality nevertheless white is
definitely going to try
uh two pieces
for a rook but all the pawns on the same
side of the board this is supposed to be
a theoretical draw
yeah yeah but you're absolutely right
with the with the two pieces I'm playing
against the Rook especially if I can get
an H4 and H5 very important expansion on
the queen king side and he did that
King F4 intriguing idea
now anytime you're going to try to put
that Bishop on the A7 G8 diagonal I'm
going to try to challenge it with my
light Square Bishop if I manage to
exchange the light Square Bishops then
it's very easy with the light Square
Bishops on the board not that easy we're
going to see Bishop C4 right now uh no
what do you think of two Bishops versus
The Rook with three and three I still
believe it's a theoretical draw
I'm less sure than you that was the
reason I asked you the question
Christian is if the night were to land
on the F5 Square would you take it I
would yes you would instantaneously and
then I would try to uh get that point to
F6 I don't know if I can get it to F6
that's the problem
okay King to D7 as he's Rook to E5
seconds for mvl 35 seconds for
yanepomyoshi once again the Challenger
of the world champion trying to
delicately control his task which is to
get
King E7
no King C7
that was a surprise move for me King
okay we're definitely keeping the bishop
oh I was expecting Bishop to E4
there Knight C6
what is White's King doing on the C7
Square
I understand close to survive Bishop C5
you have to be careful
12 seconds all right he decides to go
okay Bishop to C5 is going to be met by
Rook C4 so he cannot play that right now
correct that is a very good point
Christian
oh that allows Bishop E4 and he goes for
it uh uh wait a minute I think I took B6
Knight to B6
Bishop check
E7 he's going oh he tries to preserve
them yes he tries to keep his minor
pieces on the board clever but he may
have missed what's this bishop to C4
Bishop to C4 Rook to C2 would be a big
problem I'm sorry that is good point
indeed again the King on C7 is not
making a great five seconds
but no he's got the bishop on G4 but
that King is stuck on h8 11 seconds for
nepomyashi
and now you need to to re Focus against
the G7 Pawn
whoa why is wait okay
yeah that is good news for mvl
absolutely mvl fans are rejoicing and
again you before you press your clock
you have to make sure that your pieces
are properly on the squares and not
knocked over not to draw juice
oh my God so nervous tension once again
F4
set up a discovered attack against The
Rook very cleverly played by mvl to keep
the Rook pinning the minor pieces oh
it's all about the clock now Christian
jump in here seconds for Jane pomiyashi
12 seconds for mvl they have built some
time and now is playing all out for the
win he has this wild card flare he says
look I want to win the tournament that's
why I'm here check and King H7
no I mvl's defense has just been
magnificent it has thus far it has
indeed I'm very very impressed now we're
going to see Bishop to D oh the bishop
anymore Dead Escape is shaking that is
it we're going to see a repetition
repetition wow
Applause Just Simply simply magnificent
fantastic game Christian uh take us
through some of the results because
these two games that we witnessed had me
mesmerized I don't know what happened
scintillating defense by mvl allows him
to stay atop of the leaderboard we have
that game ended in a draw we got we got
Mama there of winning against grishuk
Duda beat Anton core above we have fan
Forest drawing Anish giri that's a very
important result for the standings that
one was a draw nepo against mvl drop and
then the one that we focused on the game
between Castro again
what happened in those last few seconds
because Gary still had five seconds on
the clock and after Bishop to C5
something happened I don't know maybe we
can get some sort of a replay of that
particular moment that was such an
intriguing moment because he just
stopped playing right it looked like
like he just froze or something there
was a complaint of something I don't
know maybe I don't know I we're going to
have to ask Gary I guess at some point
or maybe distinguish some Clues from
that replay and we do have that replay
let's see what happened
so here we have we move Queen D3
and
A5 right now he stops
seven seconds no not right now not yet
and then it was I think
the the bishop seven seconds comes to
see he has eight seconds on the clock
and this is the moment after this move
and I think we see Bishop to C5 and then
Gary just kind of froze like and looked
over and said look what happened with
the clock
and his time he just expired
no but also Vichy showed something I
don't know what he showed he pointed at
something on the board
and Gary just got
play the move Bishop to C5 exactly that
moment because something happened at
that particular moment he pointed
towards something
and that confused Gary and he decided so
we gotta just go right there yes right
right we could stop here and uh Vichy is
a knight to D4 Knight to D4 and she's
about to play Bishop C5 watch what he
does he doesn't touch that Bishop ah he
does not touch that Bishop maybe Gary
bishop and he points at something
right now
you saw that why did he point that the
flag but the flag was that right I don't
know the frustration of
maybe thinking the bishop on F5 was
going to have to move well that's the
moment yeah points at something I know
what but then what was really crazy and
against every Instinct The Grandmaster
has he froze in a Blitz game the
Instinct of every Grand Master is to
make any move you know and just not let
your clock expire so you could have
played Rook G5 Rook G3 I don't know
Queen C3 Queen your instinct is to make
any kind of a move too late yeah and it
was too late
uh
as Vichy takes 2-0 to make the measure
and let's jump to Maurice uh in Zagreb
Maurice
yeah we're trying to clear up that
mystery here guys we'll see whether or
not we can solve that problem for you
shortly I don't know what happened
either but we will definitely
investigate a couple of other important
games Duda beat Anton karbov it was very
nip and Tuck Affair up to this point in
the game and then Queen F7 check and
this is the kind of position where your
instincts take over and then prove
themselves wrong unfortunately for Anton
he put his King on h8 he should put his
King on the more exposed square of H7
who wants to do that she can just allow
Queen takes with a check on F5 the point
here though is that after Rook to C5
this Pawn on E5 is going to drop Queen
F5 is met back by King h8 and there's no
way to push this Pawn or to protect it
the pawn will leave the board this this
threat for example doesn't do anything
whatsoever as white black and always
take on B2 and then as he wishes take on
E5 and save the Checkmate the difference
will was after Queen F7 check King to h8
now Queen takes E6 now you can't play
Rook C5 why because your king is
actually more Exposed on h8 Rook f8
check and that's going to be all she
wrote after check and mate so
counter-intuitive moment where to put it
cost them a pawn and later cost him the
game another game that was very unusual
was the game between gristook and
Shakira madirov right here opposite side
castling well actually white is not yet
fully castled as you see the king moved
early in his eye on G1 but gristrict
decided let's go for it benko style
let's expand let's open up the game with
a sacrifice Bishop takes B4 and it's
right here he can now take this bishop
off the board just get rid of it then
move his King bring his Rook over to B1
bring his Bishop back to D2 and start
pumping away looking for his
compensation instead of doing that he
played Bishop to G5 F6 he takes F6 G
takes F6 and once again he should get
rid of that Bishop instead he offered an
exchange to which chakra said thank you
so much now there's very little pressure
on his castle position he went on to
take the extra pawn and just Maul him
later in the position we can jump ahead
and see that it's black if anything
dominating this position D2 rookie to
let's just trade easily and Knight takes
E3 check A desperate capture look how
White's attack went nowhere from when he
played for B4 so Shakira with a very
important point for him remember he's
got 13 Grand chests tour points he needs
to stay within Rage of Wesley so to make
it some kind of fight if he can pick up
six or seven points then that'll be
great going into St Louis there'll be
two events St Louis rapid and Blitz and
the sick field cup they are both playing
in those and Shakura will have room to
catch up with Wesley looks like third
maybe a little bit far for the moment
but if he catches fire could be a show
in this tournament and also of course
for the grand chess tour guys
thank you Maurice for those insights
please if you do manage to solve that
mystery for us what happened uh in the
game between Gary Kasparov what upset
Gary that caused him to freeze we'd
we're all ears we'd love to know
but let's just again just replay this
exact moment we've just seen the move
Bishop to C5 and
well
and naan seems to be pointing help me
out here Christian he's pointing either
at the clock
I don't think I can help you out only
the players will be able to answer those
questions right now because yeah I think
but it Whatever happened it did throw
Gary off because Gary's reaction was
such like why are you pointing at the
clock why are you doing and while
he made that complaint he
ran out of time he played the move Rook
G3 so casually I do have to say even
though this might have thrown him off
the position was complicated but
objectively I do believe that black
probably was better at this point no no
question blacks for choice but
that's a three result position for sure
especially with the players short of
time but enough of that let's just jump
to our standings Christian we have Maxim
vashir lagrav preserving his lead after
an incredible resilience resilient
defense against
19 points 18 points and a half for Jane
pomniashi Anish giri 17 points and a
half 17 points Jan Kristoff do that 17
points let me just jump in and just say
hey look at mvl's 9-0 Blitz score there
I mean he's like the 3 000 tpr
tournament performance rating of three
thousand but this year none the tiger of
Madras showing some teeth and by the way
Shaq sorry to interrupt you but Shaq is
quietly he was he was in the second half
of the table he's kind of creeping up
absolutely but I have to say I am
impressed seeing vishwanathan with eight
points that is an immense score in the
blitz portion only one point behind the
maxim vashio he is just showing his
class right now exactly he really is wow
fantastic fantastic result
and let's just see how these current
results uh look in our GCT world
we have Wesley so still at the top of
the standings with 21 points point three
and eighty two thousand five hundred
dollars we have 11 aronian in the second
position but mvl with two events played
and this is his third one he needs to
win this event and he is doing
everything and his powers to do so he is
right now only at nine GCT points not a
lot of the prices so far give him 13 he
gets 22 and then he's looking for an
epic failure by Wesley in the St Louis
rapid and Blitz but no more chests
coming your way as our summer of Chess
here in St Louis
starts off in just a few days July 15th
through the 26th we have three
concurrent national championships at
stake the U.S junior Championship the
girls and the senior championships those
senior championships for me it's kind of
light a high school reunion if you will
and then the GCT
store tour starts again with our fourth
leg the St Louis rapid and Bliss August
10th to the 16th then the granddaddy of
the mall the grand chess tour sink fill
cup August 16th to the 27th that will be
our fifth and Final
tore leg of the 2021 tour then we go to
the ultimate moves September 7th and the
champion showed down September 8th to
the 10th that's the Fisher random for
those of you who don't know what chess
9lx is and then the US and U.S women's
chess championships October 5th through
the 19th my favorite event of the Year
absolutely we have a Summer full of
Chess here in St Louis and all over the
world because the grand Chester is
international absolutely and now the
players taking their seats as they're
getting ready for round 14 and I've got
to tell you seriously he's early rounds
have really taken a lot of energy out of
me because I just feel like the players
have played some spectacular Blitz and
uh but the answer with these matchups
you know we come in the studio pretty
numb at like 6 a.m in the morning
exactly but these games are definitely
waking up truly instantaneously it's
cold slaps in the face like wake up and
it's like yeah okay okay here I mean
here I'm here and if you're not slapped
awake when two legends like Gary
Kasparov and Vichy and non sit down to
play you're not a lover of Chess because
uh for me watching those two greats uh
do get out really revives a lot of
wonderful wonderful memories so thank
you to those two players in particular
now what's our Marquee game again for
this round well uh I have to say I do
believe we're going to stick with the
nepo game on nepo against Anand will
that be the one or yes yes mvl versus
van foreign
world champion but not just a five-time
world champion I don't know how many
times he was also a challenger to the
World Championship uh might have been
five times as well and he's up against
the Challenger to the world champion
and nepo
um
facing Vichy
and facing the momentum behind vision is
just an exciting incredible Choice
exactly this is really exciting vishi I
feel like especially in his game against
Gary that she played a little bit more
Loosely with the Elan that he has had
throughout his whole career just
understanding and I think in the the the
the Rapids
he was finding his form it's very very
difficult after this huge layoff that he
had had to come to over-the-board
tournament and just you know immerse
right into the grand Chester no
absolutely he is finding his form we see
him a bit shaky uh with excitement let's
defense by the way in the previous game
but right now his old business yeah no
French defense and uh
the French defense especially in the
blitz portion we've seen him take the
Sicilian approach in pretty much all of
his Bliss games exactly this queen of
three Bishop D3 Queen G3 uh line and
whoa F7 F5 wait um holy smokes I see a
move like that and I just go no way
are you kidding me I mean and look at
this nepo who is
F6 Rook A7 and I've got all of this
prepared at my files at home King F7
what is this yes what are we watching if
you told me that this was somehow a
challenge that uh nepo has was playing a
card game last night and said tomorrow
I'm going to play King F7 against uh
Vichy Anand and the guy says I'll pay
you a thousand bucks if you do that this
must be it I mean I mean look at this
position what are we witnessing uh
do not do this at home no I
mean
every beginner is wrong okay okay make
an attempt to teach this game and the
principles behind it to a beginner right
now I'm putting you on the spot yeah sir
explain to us F5 and King to F7
disastrous disastrous F5 just doesn't
belong G5 Rook A7 G5
um first of all let's understand why we
think that white has an overwhelming
Advantage it's because of his
development yeah I mean his Rooks are
connected and so on white needs a break
ideally he would love to play the move
C2 C4 the Knight on c3a of course we
understand is in the way but when you
have an advantage in development
and your opponent's king in this case
King F7 is vulnerable you're seeking to
open up the position and from vichy's
point of view he's looking for his break
and this Rook on A7 is also a kind of a
tactical Target so I could imagine
something along the lines of Knight A3
Queen E3
the queen on G3 isn't actually ideal the
queen on E3 needs a better Square so
maybe F4 Queen E3 Queen D4 repositioning
I like vichy's position a lot
uh the question is
how to break it open advantageously of
course I did like the plan that you were
mentioning yesterday with Nightwing for
Queen to A3 now he's going for a
different plan you also have to be
careful whenever you're moving that
Knight away from the C3 Square id4
Knight is coming immediately on e4 and
this is precisely why white is not
playing the move F4 you would expect
whenever you see the move F5 this
expansion uh with F5 to immediately be
met with the move F4 try to close the
position up like that or even challenge
that pawn on G5 try to open it up on the
king side take advantage of the fact
that King is wide open on F7 the problem
with F4 you're giving away that E4
Square for the Knight forever that's why
white is keeping the pawn on F2 ready to
go to F3 controlling that Central Square
okay now having criticized laughed at
marked
what else can we say about Jan's play I
mean his position is just fine I landed
on his two feet uh it's not as bad as it
looks in this expansion has simply not
been punished
again you know it's very hard to refute
a strategy you're not expecting in Blitz
I don't think we would see this in
classical chess but F5 F4 okay uh the
bishop on C8 is no great shakes but now
that you've played the move F4 the queen
on D3 does have this diagonal towards H7
A3 so I think what vishy is saying with
this move is he intends to play B4 in
order to lock down the C5 square and to
control it hence
A5 and immediately we see this move
Knight to A4 the battle is going on
around that square C5 that you are
mentioning Yasser and also he decides to
start with A3 so that no Queen B4 is
going to be available in the position
for black could disturb also that night
and right now after the pawn moved from
A7 maybe a potential uh Landing Square
would be on B6
whoa I was thinking that F2 F3 was a
move that I would like to play the
reason I want to play the move F2 F3 is
to control the square E4 when I see the
move Bishop to G4 I get to do it with a
Tempo I can only imagine that Jan felt
that his King could use an extra
Defender Bishop that I'm seeing from
vishi's point of view Queen C3 that's a
problem give me the pawn and that's why
he played Bishop D7 and now Knight C5
and queen C3 and I believe
big Edge I do believe for white Jan
missed the move Queen to C3 he was
planning exactly what you were
mentioning
six but then he thought oh my God where
is the queen going to go oh the Queen's
gonna go to C3 where it's great and by
the way Knight C5 Bishop D7 the Jan's
last two three moves F4 Bishop G4 Bishop
D7 Bishop C8 I think is a disaster now
he's trying to make a virtue of what he
just did which I think was spoil his
position with the move G4 uh I'm
thinking
guess what I'm gonna take this guy
you're gonna take with the bishop I'm
gonna play Rook to f
Rook to D2 to F2 and wow that she just
said Oh I thought vichy's intention was
to play Knight E5 check but he
recaptured instantly on F3 Vichy I might
have to give him a membership to the
pond grubber Society there he's looking
at that F Pawn say saying you put it
there it's vulnerable I want it
absolutely and we do have this queen C6
is also every Queen A5 there's so many
things
it's so difficult rookie one as well
absolutely that's very nice yeah for 95
Queen takes c66 Queen take A5 there's so
many pawns hanging right now in Black's
position you will not be able to defend
all of them you have to uh maneuver your
pieces towards the white king so I'm
expecting something along the lines of
Rook to G8 at some point and try to get
to that King if you don't get to that
strategically you're in big trouble as
black whoa whoa whoa
D7 and the idea Bishop takes G7 Rook to
G8 you haven't blundered a piece but
can't be good can it okay so first of
all I could take the pawn I like rookie
one though rookie one unfortunately just
invites Queen G5 check darn it
rats
King H1 sidestepping Rook g seven fours
I think maybe it's time to round up the
little fella here I like the move Queen
D4 followed by Queen takes F4 maybe
vishi is even considering Queen takes
that looks a little bit more dangerous
no that's not the move no no no no no no
he probably took on C6 I do think we
have yes he did yeah I was about to say
that's not let me let me take that one
back uh and yes correct our score sheet
please Queen takes C6 this she's saying
gift what's better than winning one Pawn
I guess winning two pawns very good the
correct answer
that is indeed better than one yeah okay
I mean you're not gonna hear it on
Jeopardy but you know just in case
Bishop H3 stopping Queen G1 looks to me
like Vichy is taking the Challenger down
wow it's not so fast wait a minute three
is protecting against the Checkmate on
G2 I can't move it away and the game is
over correct but look at this everything
is hanging in Black's Camp
95 maybe could be a movie distract the
queen and then take on C8 but then Queen
to E2 is landing I'm I don't know I
don't know what's happening I think
vishu is starting to look for some
Perpetual because that action of the
queen and the Rook on the G file is so
dangerous right now you need well it's
either that or Rook to E1 works and I'm
the one checkmating you first
let's see what he did he played
G4 no that's an incredible you cannot
take the pawn on G4 because of Knight to
E5 what a move Bishop G4 I mean
staggeringly
what understanding an amazing move to my
eyes Bishop to G forward so now he's got
Queen E6 check Knight E5 don't forget
that the Knight is hanging and don't
forget also that I've got my Rook on the
first rank defending G1 as soon as I
take this Pawn on
D5 I'm defending G2
this looks great for Vichy
let's go
he won the last we're entering the last
minute
the game and maybe we do it for fishy
Rook E1 rookie one I think Vichy has
this game
under control 43 seconds for vishy is
getting a minute and 14 seconds for nepo
oh my gosh
this year was a just be three wow oh no
no no no B3 no I'm not a fan you wanted
to play I think he wanted to play Rook
E5 and I don't understand why he didn't
play it okay the night on B6 was doing
nothing we say queen 26 okay getting
ready to exchange those Queens via Queen
to F5 that was a little bit of a hiccup
by Vichy there I think he was cruising
smoothly to Victory with the move Rook
E5 Queen to H4 and now we've got Queen
F5 check
I feel like it has to go for no Queen to
G6 is the chosen move
Queen to F5 is going to change the
queens that is a good step forward for
viciana well here's a pawn up after all
yeah but I I think somehow the worst is
no no I you you saw it there some
nervousness by Ian and queen takes F4
and rookie seven check
ooh he's going for she's back in the
driver's seat it's going for his Rook C7
nepo realizes that Rook E7 check is all
she wrote I'm not just a game by
vishanan right now heading straight
towards a victory
can he
deliver the full point though what's the
time situation 22 seconds for Vichy 30
29 seconds for uh foreign
drama here
and he's invited Rook E7 wait a minute
what is that Rook 27 King to h8 the only
move the only movement to E6 and that's
why we play threatens the night and the
Knight is pinned the Knight on F2 is
brilliant
H3 holy smokes he's playing against the
game
slowly but Queen to e five yes yes he
went for it
I know he's threatening G5 Knight G4
rookie seven the threats are all one-way
traffic this is game over it's it's a
beautiful game G5 rookie seven these
moves play themselves Queen E6 check
Rook F7 this is game over Yasser oh a
beautiful game fishing takes it home oh
wait a minute he's won yes King and
careful for
The Rook is not hanging incredible okay
check incredible and simply G5 G6
no surprise move that he yeah incredible
whoo
one game left let's quickly jump to it
but vishy showing his class as he takes
down
uh the Challenger and what game is it it
looks like the game versus Duda very
important game
trying to get it up on my board but I
don't see it
all right we have
one I'm trying to pick up the position
at the moment it looks like rook and
Bishop Rook takes E5 he did not see that
movie you could see it on his face
giving away the bishop but that H Pawn
is going down the board how do you stop
it Bishop C6 Bishop Bishop C6 Bishop
takes E5 that's a good move H Rook takes
and this should one king F1
oh A7 uh also I have a pawn as an extra
Bishop an extra Bishop yeah
and just move the bishop bring that
Bishop back to E2 a resignation
check yeah no no Chuck and now Rook to
H5 and yeah now he now he's feeling it
just to gain some time on the clock
King F2 nicely done sometime on the
clock
you oh you do get two seconds for each
move that you complete check Shack and
now that's your Bishop have to attack
that pawn on e4 precisely Bishop to D1
Rook to C5 Bishop to C2 hit that pawn on
on e4 and that will be all she wrote
King D6 has to be played King D6 Rook C4
probably now you can activate your king
king to D2 to C3
check check on D4 no wave four strange
well everything is tied up right King to
C3 and now push that thing away and then
King D5 again and then you pick up the
E4 Pawn thank you very much
Shaq
my pick
overall pick to win the tournament I
should say not the right pick for the
blitz running up the standings she's
definitely doing well could you uh tell
us all the results yes absolutely so
with this one Mama diarov Drew up one
against Duda we have a draw in the game
between Maximus and Van Forest Anand won
his game against napoleonashi Dragon
here we go down oh yes giri against
grishook that was a draw important and
we have another decisive result and that
is the clash between Anton corabov and
Gary Kasparov ended in coroboth's favor
and mvl a full point of ahead
thanks to vishianan guess who's buying
dinner tonight uh and the yellow is a
very important wait a minute vicious
inching closer and closer to those
leadership positions I'm not 100 sure
how far behind he is but I don't think
it's more than a point and a half type
of her he's tight for third okay okay
yeah wow okay uh but by the way uh I
just thought that was a great game by
Vichy I don't know about the opening
strategy of nepos uh but uh here's the
end a replay of that game as this year
none just has got this dominant position
of the queen on E5 The Rook on E6 he's
threatening Rook to E7 he's got ideas
like G5 and Knight G4 as well that
Knight on F2 was such a staple of
Defense it was brilliant and then
the check and Rook F7 he can play these
moves in his sleep he knows exactly what
he's trying to do he's filling it right
yes he's just simply filling it yes
and now Queen to G6 he also had in that
position Queen f8 check I thought that
that was a good move
but picking up the pawn not that and
King G2 especially that was a very
beautiful touch if you play Rook F4 I've
got Queen H6 check there goes the Rook
there goes the Knight nepo says thank
you very much
for the lesson that was exactly exactly
thank you very much for the lesson but
you're asking for a lesson when you're
playing a movie such as F5 and King F7
in the first 10 moves certainly our
Maurice jump in how are you my friend
let me tell you I'm just stunned by
today's Fighting Chess the belligerence
I'm counting out of 25 games maybe you
guys can help me I think I'm right two
four five six seven eight
25 games we have 17 wins and eight draws
17 wins what kind of percentage is this
every round we're seeing at least three
wins happen it's absolutely incredible
just how many top games top players are
bashing each other over the head one
game though we do have to note as there
were a number of key draws as mvl only
drew his last game but there was
and and grishek and Anish also Drew
chakra mamajira also on the rise we're
talking about Anna and being on the rise
Shakura cementing himself with this
comeback so that he can get those
critical Grand chest tour points that's
huge remember Anan is a wild card is
part of the tour so he's trying to get
points desperately and he's making up
some much needed ground and putting
pressure on Wesley so the one game that
was sad was the game between
Antonio casparov I got to go to this
position guys we have this in the
opening it's it's a king's Indian Gary's
going for it F5 F3 Bishop D7 A3
and in this position Gary played a move
that you say every Russian Schoolboy
knows don't do it he took on e4 it's
like allowing a knight to cement itself
on the E4 Square it's like that's that
stuff we learned from guys like him you
can't do that Knight F4 castles
eight six night takes on F4 about to win
a pawn if you capture back on their
Force it's going to be a straight Pawn
hg5 Knight to D3 and look at those
Knights Bishop F5 Rook to E1
and I got to tell you here he stopped
playing I mean how do you resign in this
position strategically dominant for
white but
make some moves all right get you me
drop your G Pawn if you play G4 play the
game end up losing here he had a minute
and 25 seconds on his clock he's been
pacing outside this room
since that game was over
at least 10 minutes 15 minutes ago he
has not stopped pacing back and forth
he's like uh prowling tiger
must be angry at himself furious at this
I mean I don't want to put any words to
it how bad he must feel right now how
angry that that he's in the situation
he's in
we uh we'll just keep following the
story guys at any rate their leaders to
look at nepo definitely not happy how
he's going backwards and mvl doing his
thing guys thank you Maurice and here we
have our standings Christian Maxim
vashir lagrav extending his lead at the
top such a dominant performance in the
blitz section with nine points and a
half total score 19 points and a half
leading by one point in second position
Anish giri in third position
also in third position he is showing his
stuff in this tournament no question
about it nine out of 14 I'm thinking
that's a
28 50 2900 tournament performance rating
the tiger from Madras is roaring that is
wow that you just take off your hat and
say Well done and let's take a look at
the pairings for the round that's coming
up round 15 Christian we have Alexander
grishuk against mvl and I do believe
that this will be the Marky matchup of
the round for us we will be following
the leader on this one Jordan van Forest
is going to be facing janapo miyashi
with the white pieces nepo needs to
bounce back after this very difficult
loss against uh we have Carrie Casper
versus
we have Jan Christoph Duda versus Anish
giri and Anton korob versus
thank you Christian well we're just
gonna take a moment to catch our breath
stay with us and we'll see you on the
other side of the break
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the grand chest tour
time flies by when you're having fun and
it flies quickly in Blitz chess we are
ready for round 15 let's take a look at
the standings after 14 rounds of Blitz
look what we got Christian we have mvl
at the top of the standings dominated
the blitz portion with 19 points and a
half yanepomyashree losing some steam in
uh today's rounds 18 points and a half
in second position Anish giri 18 points
wow the tiger form Madras who is just
simply roaring in the blitz tournament
nine points out of 14 games that's an
amazing achievement shackriors
kind of coming up a bit as well eight
and a half points not bad but let's take
a look at the pairings for this round
15. Christian we have graystroke versus
mvl that will be our Marquee matchup of
the round we have van Forest versus
napomniashi we have Kasparov versus
mamadiarov we have Duda versus Anish
Theory and Anton karabov versus
vishwanathan
matchups of course but Sasha Grisha has
had a very uneven result but at times it
seems like he's playing ambitiously and
then other times it just kind of goes
into this kind of peaceful mode uh
speaking of peaceful
he he looks like he's just getting a
little nap before the game and there it
is the starters pistol and they're off
Knight F3 C5 Knight F3 is kind of I want
to say an anecdote or for the groomfeld
when you don't want your opponent to
play groomfeld you can sort of take it
out of him oh look at this they're
playing very quickly into a tarash I I'm
expecting Knight takes D5 yes
by mvl he doesn't want to see a straight
tarash with E6 takes D5 now just to
recall his file
and what can you tell us about this line
Christian it should be a very very equal
Knight takes D4 Queen takes D4 we're
seeing potentially an exchange of the
Queensland actually that is exactly
what's up
just kind of came in and just swept half
the pieces off the board my goodness
that happened very quickly I think uh
Alexander is just happy with her draw it
seems like
and let's jump to zagrev for the quick
thought from our colleague Maurice
Ashley Maurice
I just wanted to say guys you should
know what Shakura mama zeroth is doing
so far on this day he drew in the first
round against Maxine vashilagrov he
proceeded to beat nepo in the next game
then he beat von Forrest then he beat
gristook then he also won his last name
against Duda he's four and a half out of
five he's having a scintillating
performance right now the best
performance of anyone in the event today
and he plays Gary right now Gary up
against the wall as shock is rising
trying to at least get some critical
Grand chess tour points guys back to you
thank you for that Maurice absolutely
which is one of the reasons I actually
chose
Shaq as my overall pick I think that
he's really underestimated in Blitz and
uh you know again just coming off of
that superb tournament in Bucharest you
were at Christian you know what kind of
form he said when a player of his
caliber is playing his best it can be
unstoppable no absolutely he's just a
scary man whenever he feels good and
this was key in that event he was just
enjoying himself he was happy to be back
at the chessboard after a period of
inactivity and he just wanted to play
chess a man like that just wanting to
play chess just wanting to be happy and
play moves and and just get accumulate
this experience and enjoy it over the
chessboard is a scary man to behold
absolutely
I was just checking uh our second
table because I'm just seeing this
ending that Maxine and Sasha is trying
for something he's trying for a little
bit
is well you as a grunfeld player
understand the queen side majority
versus the central majority uh in this
position it just feels like the C file
is going to end up being a chopping
block for the Rooks and I'm just seeing
more trades and more trades Rook is
going to come to C8 Bishop is going to
come to E6 and I just don't see why
black isn't
happy more than satisfied in fact
there's no reason for our black to be
worse at this point exactly it seems
like uh he definitely achieved
everything he wanted out of the opening
to be honest Alexander was not very
ambitious ambitious exactly in this game
exactly he wasn't ambitious the opening
really didn't hold much promise
um now having said that we said that in
the game between
you did yeah you called a draw I agree
and it turned out to be quite the Donnie
Brook after all I agree and we saw that
stalemate pattern in the rook and
beautiful beautiful and if you guys
don't know what I'm talking about after
the show look it up rewind look it up
because that's just such a beautiful
example of how to defend that uh end
game but right now to be honest I'm
seeing this exchange on E6 I like this
for black because that stops the
majority of whites on the king side in
its tracks I already have control of the
C file I'm going to defend that seventh
rank with root B7 or Rook to C7 put the
King on F7 and I think I have a very
very compact position easy to defend I
don't think white is going to uh have
any sort of Demands at an advantage at
this point exactly I like the idea of
Rook B7 not Rook C7 of course
commentators curse
I wanted to have the Rook becoming
active down the C file so I wanted to
play Rook B7 so I could play Rook C2 and
King F7 he did get in those moves now
Rook D7 is simply going to be met by
Rook on B7 to B uh Rook on B8 to B7 that
is to say had white played the move Rook
the B5
that is a very strange timing B5 now
you're inviting Rook here and you can't
meet Rook to D7 with Rook to B7
or why is that I I apologize uh
good morning Saint Louis
it's uh it's an early morning for us
here each and every day each and every
day excuses excuses
I fully confess my bad
uh B G4 again I like I like what black
has done on the king side as he's
putting his pawns on light squares and
this bishop is no great shakes
King to E4
only one idea behind this move which is
to play at F5 I a little bit surprised
by the move Rook B7 frankly I thought
his idea was to play B5 A5 and A4 ASAP
get those doggies moving on the king
side but Rook B7
did he really need to waste that Tempo
Christian uh probably not but uh what
Maxim is doing right now is playing very
fast he's putting a lot of pressure on
the time he has a bit less than four
minutes three minutes and 40 seconds 40
seconds and counting right now and
Alexander has one minute and 30 seconds
only left on the clock so with this one
potentially becoming a race between my
pawns my majority on the queen side the
neural majority on the king side
time could play a crucial part
it always has especially in Blitz Rook
seat for check Rook D4 Rook
one pair of Rooks was traded on D4 I
don't see uh yeah he did capture with
the bishop we're going to see on a B4
okay
so he's getting ready to create that
pass pawn and again F5 there's no other
choice you'd need to get now the
question is if you take wait a minute
King takes E6 is coming and that would
be very unpleasant so he's CH he's given
white the opportunity to get a protected
pass Pawn now white is that C6 Square
once put the Rook on C6 and that's going
to force well wait a minute A4 Rook to
C6 and now B3
no exactly took on F5 he took an F5 with
chain he took on F5 with track so A4 was
played Rook to C6 was played takes takes
and now after B4 this is the problem
there are some threats with the move E6
hence the move Rook to B5 to pin the
pawn and not allow his opponent E6 we're
getting very close to the time trouble
situation so maybe we can switch to the
bird's eye view to see the players and
uh there you got it there we go they're
playing fast right now yeah shout out to
our producer Tom normally he never
follows our lead that that was that was
really remarkable I don't know how we
managed to do that when did you send
them a Christmas card or something
I think Tom's wide awake today uh
remarkable
no absolutely and that bishopon B2 is
doing a tremendous job
okay it certainly is and this is
actually an awkward moment
for mvl because in a certain sense he's
kind of maximized his position uh his
Rook stands well his King stands as well
is possible the bishop is is good
um
this is a double-edged position yes he
doesn't know exactly how he should
continue because he's reached a position
where everything is okay and it's not
easy to find
the next move it should be very shallow
and he's going to come back with his
Rook Chad are we going to see a
repetition I don't think so I think King
E4 rookcha King F5 Rook B5 is is and
let's see if he tries to go for king of
F5 I'm for sure we I I I will expect
king of five and not a repeat king of
five Rook B5 and then I cannot let you
go E6 that's no I cannot let you go E6
never never the king of five rookie five
Rook to see oh
yeah well the thing is right now Grisha
Clark only has 32 seconds against two
minutes that's a big time differential
that you might not want to play with
um mvl considering the move Rook H4 I I
think that's playing with fire myself
but otherwise why he hasn't played Rook
B5 already King E4 I think you can we're
going to see a draw yeah okay let's
switch quickly where what was our second
game all of our game all of the games
are still ongoing so uh let's jump
should we jump to Van Forest against
Nepal yes exactly
well uh I'm seeing a repetition and
nepo I mean not Bridging the Gap with a
leader right now exactly that's a big
opportunity because we know Jordan is
struggling in last position nevertheless
it's but this there's still some play
left but yeah this should be a draw
there should be yeah this looks good
enough uh Jordan has doubled up his
Rooks and just moved the king
okay
and who's playing for a win here
I'm trying to understand who's playing
for a win here well Gian is playing for
the win before he played the move H5 I
thought he was going to play
you're still not threatening to take on
F5 because I'm still within the range
the drawing why not drawing actually
just winning after that because you're
within the square right you cannot take
on F5
and you cannot push the B Pawn because
the queen would take it
you know I play King H3 I can take on F5
yes with this move Rook takes F5 is now
a threat make a draw correct to make a
draw
well not at this particular moment you
have to be very careful about it okay
I'm going to play Rook F4 no yes now yes
oh wait a minute no F7 is hanging so
wait a minute Queen takes a five
take take King to H3 yes you get in time
you're you're just in time
are you though wait wait wait a minute
yeah you are in time you are in time yes
exactly right what you don't want to see
is the Pawn on F5 and the King on E5
then when you approach I you got to play
King H4 it's the only move
and he's done it anything else would
have lost the game because F now you
have to pay five on H5 only move
and by the way a hat-trick
this Vichy
has won his third game in a row as both
players Queen
uh I like that just shove the pawn out
of the way just bulldoze the tray the
Queens boys
the green tray the quiz there we go nice
nicely done
whoo
one game left let's quickly turn to it
and that's a game between Duda and Anish
very important game actually for when
you think about uh these players have
played a very good Blitz tournament to
start with and they stand well in the
standings nice
tour points and prize money
here black had the option of keeping the
Queens on the board but he decided
against that what's the time Factor
because again normally speaking
five seconds for Duda 15 for giri wow
well with the with that edge on the
clock and that's expected yeah I would
have expected the Queens to remain on
the board when you have more time you
want to oh you're right about that yes
yes you want to keep your opponent
a challenge are you getting in trouble
right now no I don't think so F5 whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa oh and he
knocked over yeah black was in Susan I
think right now Duda is in poor position
to win this one absolutely and whoa whoa
whoa one second he made that move with
one second
so that's what I'm saying the instinct
when you play Blitz your instinct is not
to freeze but to play instantly
and again it's kind of a zook swing he's
saying to Anish declare where you're oh
Bishop F5 resigned game over yeah wow
what a missed opportunity for English
fighter uh he he he showed some great
technique in that game Christian wow but
first of all tell us the results what
happened in this room let's look at the
results so what do we have right now we
have Anton corabov losing against
who can place the hat-trick and is right
now inching closer to that leadership
position right now it's only a point and
a half behind the leader
he's just making an incredible comeback
after the rapid portion then we have
Kasparov did lose against muhammadiara
of Mama they are confused he's run five
and a half out of six Yasser I'm telling
you a fantastic Duda bid Anish grishuk
uh Drew against vashio degrava and Van
Forest Drew against Nepal but we do have
more recent Zagreb with some new
information Maurice
well the deal is that nepo uh faded he
lost two games on a day when he was only
a half a point ahead of Maxime coming
into the round Maxim has won a one game
he simply won his game and watched nepo
go backwards and he's drawn all the rest
it looks like he's having this fantastic
results and he's only won one game he is
not the story of the day although he is
leading right now the two stories first
of all chakra mom Madeira of five and a
half out of six that's amazing chakra is
not known as a village player but this
he's continuing his games his great play
we can get into this game frankly Gary
had a great position Gary just had a
good position right here Bishop takes on
F6 was played by Gary and instead of
just taking back normally what Bishop
takes that would allow the Knight on C
on A4 to get to C5 he said you know what
I'm going to go crazy after Bishop F6
I'm just going to take and this caused
Gary to tank when the pawn takes
happened on the board he played Knight
G4 H5 and again Gary paused here and
panicked with Queen to E2 and suddenly
he was in big trouble King to G7 a star
defensive move shutting down what looked
like the beginning of a big attack Rook
to F3 going all in Shakira said I'll
take this Knight and he could take the
other one he said I won't even bother
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
make sure you have zero attack up a
piece your position is going nowhere
fast and Shakura once again with five
and a half out of six that's a huge
Story the next big story of course is
anan's game he had this position where
he was winning easily he won the game
anyway but we can go back to right here
when he took on G2 dominant position
Rook F3 Rook B1 King H2 in here a small
slip with the move Rook to H1 check King
G3 we saw this finish I'm gonna go back
in a second but here after check the
correct move is King to G2 and after
taste King 2 F2 and here he's upper past
Pawn but certainly a tricky position to
win instead of this that could have
happened what should have happened was
after Rook F3 work check King H2 the
very devilish Rook to F1 would have been
all she wrote as now your Rook is going
to be captured The Rook that is on F3
because G1 check is threatened and
there's nothing to do about it Rook
takes of course met by G1 Queens takes
and give me that with a very easy win in
this position his opponent did not put
up much resistance and he won the game
so Vichy Rising now in the tie for
second but chakria right there as well
we got two of the Elder players on fire
right now as the leaders are going to be
watching their back where did these guys
come from the rise of the ogs guys back
to you
thank you Maurice as we take a look at
our standings first of all uh the blitz
you see down look at this she showing
his class he's got Ted and he's tied
with Maxine for the best overall Blitz
score but it's about the current scores
uh Christian did I say Vichy is a point
and a half behind the leader no he is
one point behind the leader that is one
game this matches are so contested this
tournament is going to go down to the
wire as we enter the final stretch the
final third of the event and we have
Maxim vashiolograph in the poor position
with 20 points Jana ponies
with 19 points
your pick Shack rising Rising yeah the
Jaws music is playing 18 and a half
points one and a half points behind
continue
and Yan Kristoff do that on 18 points
that was a very important matchup
between the two of them because with
that Victory
pulled our Niche backwards exactly yeah
that was my pick that was a difficult
game to watch I have to say for me
Alexander Grace shook 16 points Anton
karobah 14 and a half points Kasparov
slash sorry struggling 11 and a half
points and Jordan van forest with 10 and
a half points in 10th position and let's
take a look at our upcoming pairings for
this round 16 if we have those available
and
still catching my breath from all of
these games Christian that's at the
table for us please the first game is
going to be the matchup of the Marquee
matchup of the round that is faster the
graph against Jan Kristoff do that then
we're going to have the battle of the
Russians versus Alexander grishukri
armamediaro versus Anton karabov Anish
giri versus Gary Kasparov and
vishwanathan versus Jordan van Forest
exactly Vichy a non-coming from a hat
trick of three consecutive wins putting
himself in a position to be a threat
slow down the young man
and this is a remarkable I mean vicious
it's looking so good and again he's just
playing a little bit more with that
Evolution that made him so dangerous as
a world champion he just he feels the
game and when he's informed it's a joy
to behold it's very very nice and we're
going to start to take a look at the
road ahead for some of our tournament
leaders because I mean this jockeying
for position has just been great Maurice
opened the show showing how the lead
changes occurred in day one of Blitz and
this
the this uh day two has really been
great fun we don't want to jinx anything
but here is a potential playoff scenario
event of a tie for first place in any of
the 2021 rapid and Blitz grandchester
events there will be a playoff a play
playoff amongst all the players involved
in the tie we're not going to be looking
at any tie breaks we're just going to
play chess if two players are tight
we're going to have a rapid double round
robin that is game in 10 minutes with a
10 second increment that is a faster
time control than in the first three
days of the event if three or more
players are tied then we're going to
have a blitz round rabbit that's going
to be game in five minutes with a 2
second increment if after those Rapid or
Blitz round Robins we're still going to
be tied then we're going to have an
Armageddon that's going to be five
minutes for the white pieces against
four minutes for the black pieces
there's no increment there's no delay
and black will win in case of a draw but
that's when our hearts will start even
harder than they are right now exactly
this Armageddon games boy they're really
really tough on the fans but also the
players now as I'm looking at uh our
around 16 coming up I really do need to
make a shout out to our sponsors uh do
Take a Look shop at Q Boutique our grand
chest tour merchandise as a coming in
new merchandise is coming into the store
and we are running a very handsome
discount so take a look at qbetic St
louis.com also a very big shout out to
our partners at kasparovchess.com we
hope you've been enjoying the mini
documentaries as well as chess lessons
again you can use a coupon code to get a
significant discount on the memberships
so please do check that out at
casparovchess.com but now now let's take
a look at the road ahead for MBL
Christian
he has a young Christophe Duda in round
16 with the white pieces then in round
17 penultimate round of the tournament
he's going to be facing Gary Kasparov
with the black pieces then we're going
to have in round 18 with the white
pieces against Anton corabov right an
intriguing road ahead but dare I say
accessible road ahead yeah dangerous uh
final round what who will show up in the
Gary Kasparov match we're not sure but
this is going to be huge this round 16
this game that Duda just won against our
Niche he's feeling it and he knows that
if he can win he could pull mvl back as
well as gain a point on our tournament
leader so that's a very important uh
game and again that will be our Marquee
matchup but we've been a and treated to
so many great games so big shout out to
the players I mean they're just bringing
it and
you know as we say it takes two to tango
but in this case it takes 10 11 players
to tango and I've just been trying to
catch my breath and stay up with the
players uh Christian it's been wonderful
to watch yes sir the games have been
amazing and we see a a tale of two
stories right now Alexander grishuk and
vishwanathan with a little lunch but
also a bit of preparation I can
guarantee you right now he is looking at
his files he knows what he's going to do
next probably his seconds from uh India
or whoever is helping him during this
event has sent him some new information
and right now he's just Gathering that
information ready to unleash it on his
opponents
cool and let's take a look at nepo's uh
road ahead for his remaining three games
Christian he has a white pieces against
Alexander grishchuk an interesting
the the two players share two opponents
they should they share Duda and Kasparov
together
and then in round eight he's going to be
taking mvl's
um and I do think we have the wrong
numbers there is round 16 17 and 18
right now we were seeing seven eight and
nine and then in the last round he is
facing Gary Casper exactly and
nepo coming to the board again the
Challenger to Magnus Carlson world
champion all Russian Derby matchup here
remind me on the first Blitz game I
believe nepo won I remember the rapid no
no no he didn't hit it so NEPA won in
the rapid right I have to say nepo one
in the blitz as well maybe and then the
the blitz for sure maybe oh boy no no no
the rapid is for sure the rapid he he
did win in the rapid portion we we had
that English
yes that he nicely outplayed him now he
came with the white places once again
why is Napa being so successful in your
opinion with the move C4 and G3 I mean
he's just beating the world's elite
players like
he's been analyzing it for many years
but let's get a thought about this round
from Maurice in Zagreb
just wanted to point out this the
running theme that we've got to go on is
the grand Chester standings right now we
see the rise of two players that is Anan
and nepo those two players are stealing
points away from the rest of the tour if
Anan stays in a position he's in or
Rises he's taking away a chunk of points
that he can't use it's like those chips
of the casino when you leave they're no
good for anything so that's a big deal
that that's happening big point but
chakra Madeira with 13 points his rise
is super important because he'll get at
least seven with a fourth place finish
seven points will put him at 20 if all
ended right now he would be at 20 points
on the grand chest tour you see how
close that would put him to Wesley and
if he can somehow overtake the the
leader the two people ahead of him he
might get eight or ten points chakra
will have the lead in The Grand chess
tour over Wesley so so that is critical
to watch for as we watch the rest of
these three rounds big big games ahead
absolutely thank you for that Maurice
and let's just take a quick look at
vichy's road ahead
in round 16 he's going to be facing van
forest with the white pieces in round 17
he is going to be facing shakrian of
William black pieces that is a huge game
indeed and in the last round he's going
to be facing oh man he faced so many
times and that is Alexander grishock
with the white pieces and as the players
get ready this will be our Marquee
matchup mvl our tournament leader up
against yanduda of Poland and a big
shout out for those of you who weren't
paying attention but Michael korsakovsky
has announced that next year Warsaw will
be a host to a Blitzen rapid Grand chest
Tour event hello Poland hello Poland
indeed and hello Jan Christoph Duda
because we're going to see him in that
event
who knows we don't want to give out any
information right now let's send out the
advice uh yeah sure but we're going to
find those uh invites in in some time in
some months and
the handshake and they are off E4 a
acara Khan
my favorite
two nights variation with Knight
c38 cool explains that four well the
idea is you want to play a French
defense uh and you don't want to play
Knight E4 Knight E2 your knight might
get trapped and if you played Knight to
D7 you are blocking the bishop so Knight
G8 even though you lose a lot of time
and you're seating white uh advantage in
the center the fact that your Bishop is
not trapped behind your Pawn structure
but is standing on the G4 Square uh give
some relief to black but again you're
losing a lot of time here no absolutely
uh
what what strikes me the most is these
players play so nonchalantly move such
as Knight to G8 and nobody's face oh
yeah and nobody's face they're like oh
yeah yeah sure yeah I was expecting this
you know 98 I'm gonna play Bishop P2
immediately you know because I know what
I'm supposed to do against Nigeria if I
if I would see Nigeria I would be
looking at my opponent and I would have
like some sort of a are you kidding me
yeah
uh I really a little bit stunned by
Bishop F5 by Bishop H5
and uh some very peculiar looking move
shall we say okay now it's time for the
typical uh
French brake C7 C5 in this case c6e5
breaking up White's Central bonduo and
by the way I mean
what the heck is going on here mdl
playing some we are trousers
felt like helping me because I did want
to go Bishop to G6 right okay I am a
pawn grubber this might be asking too
much yes no Knight takes D4 Queen takes
D4 Bishop takes C2 there is Knight takes
E6 it's so peculiar to have a bishop on
H5 uh hitting the the king
that Bishop take C2 Knight E6 wasn't
obvious but as is common in a French
defense black is looking to post his
Knight up on F5 by the way Queen A4
check Queen D7 I would be elated to
trade Queens as black even though I lose
castling privileges
um taking off the Queens is helpful for
the second player
my first impression is black is
satisfied but this was a very strange
mix of opening moves here I I must say
that is also my first impression the
answer uh indeed and I think we do have
a knight takes G6 so he chose the bishop
pair in this position HD hd6 Bishop to
E2 now we're probably going to see a
knight coming to F5 we're going to see
Bishop to B5 and then the king will have
to go to f8 now the big question Queen
24 okay King goes to f8 nonetheless you
do not want to go Queen this hour Queen
D7 would have been met
you'd hurt my feelings Bishop B5 now I
don't know why he didn't just Castle
he's keeping Rook H4 potentially in
reserve Rook h8 to H4 I believe he
decided as a way of developing his Rook
he decided that that rookie is just more
active on the H file than it would have
been on a f8 fighting for for that C
file with the Rook from A8 so I think
okay the Roku nitrate will go via the H
line somewhere it's going to land
probably on an active Square on H4 I
would say as you are mentioning yes sir
yeah and The Rook from 8 probably will
learn to see it Rook to H oh I was about
to say Rook to H4 F4 Bishop C5 check and
Knight G3 mate is a nasty nasty way of
uh finishing the game now with the movie
my way of thinking this opens up the
possibility of Queen to H4 uh
which would force the trade of Queen
something that black is trying to
achieve which is why mvl played G3
my thought is that this position is uh
quite acceptable for for for black but
never forget the two Bishops can be a
significant advantage in this particular
position the C file is a closed thanks
to the bishop on D3 protecting the pawn
on C2 uh your knee-jerk thoughts uh
Christian do you like white or black
well one thing I will say Yasser is that
I did spot mvl look at the digital
boards that show all the games that are
being in progress he took a glance at
them to see who's following watching
what his following peers are doing right
now is he happy with her draw is he
going to try to push for a win this is a
key game because going into the final
two championship rounds yep with a point
and a half a point ahead that's a huge
margin but if he loses this one a lot of
players can slowly catch up in yeah do
that also with a win in this one he
would be only one point behind mvl
absolutely he match up right here do the
spending some significant time after
this move uh G3 and queen F4 not
allowing the trade of Queens it took a
while for him to play the move Queen B6
the combination of the moves Bishop C5
and queen B6
I don't like simply be because the
bishop on C5 is in the way of The Rook
if he wanted to control that diagonal uh
Queen B6 was the way I think he needed
to play Rook H4 earlier the move G2 G3
was very useful I don't understand this
move C3 unless he was afraid that the
queen was going to come to B4 and he was
a going to have to trade Queens if I'm
white I'm playing King G2 and H4 ASAP by
the way the bishop did drop back an
indication that Duda was not satisfied
with the bishop on C5 Christian exactly
and as you were mentioning yes sir that
idea of C3 was to play B4 kick the
bishop off and then defend that C3 Pawn
with the bishop Bishop to D2 connecting
the Rooks then expanding on the queen
side A4 A5 and try and take some space
over there black decided to play Bishop
to E7 for that particular reason now you
cannot play B4 because that pawn on C3
is hanging you cannot move the bishop
because the quantum B2 hanging so what
is left that pawn on A2 to be moved and
to try to attack the queen with A5 I
think this is what we're seeing right
now on the board we saw A4 A6 right now
we saw Rook to E1 G5 and G6 A5 attacking
the queen right now I'm just being told
by the way that Vichy is dominating at
this exact moment that is just some
extraordinary results by uh this is
playing van forest with the white pieces
that's a golden opportunity to try to
creep in close absolutely leadership and
I wanted to say that
my desirable idea of getting the king to
G2 and upon the H4 which would have shut
down the play along the H5 was not
achieved and Duda was very quick to play
the move G6 G5 which came with the tempo
followed by G7 G6 now that his King is
off the back rank he has this
opportunity of doubling his Rooks on the
H file and he's done that and he's
forced The Rook that was on E1 to go
back to H1 maybe leaving the potential
for a wheat Pawn on E5 Queen to oops
excuse me I think that was me Queen no
uh Queen I was trying to play the move
Queen to C7 and uh my auto update uh put
the queen on C6 and I was like fighting
with my computer what's wrong with you I
wanted to play Queen seven a moment ago
and he's done it now Queen C7
mvl
is
getting into a very dangerous situation
dangerous situation in my view this move
hits two peskies and he's going to get
one of them right well he played C3 C4
which does have the benefit that the
bishop if you grab the E5 Pawn just pay
attention to a bishop to C3 uh
how real is that how can he get can he
essay the pawn grab this is what Buddha
is calculating as we speak exactly and
by the way the move c3c forward he did
not detect he did not take he played the
move a rook to d8
taking advantage of those two Bishops
kind of stuck right now at least
momentarily we have a bit of a traffic
jam no question about that but this move
Rook d8 is a relief because now the
bishop actually uh is anchored on C3 and
the two weaknesses the pawns on A5 and
E5 are properly covered how do you
engineer the trade of dark squared
Bishops is black
taking well with B5 you're kind of
releasing the queen uh from the defense
of those Queen side pawns because you
know Bishop E4 was going to come on the
board and that was going to create some
problems against that point on B7 you
want to get rid of that weakness and
this is what he is doing right now I'm
not agreeing necessarily with what he's
doing because white managed to uh get
that Rook on a for attacking the pawn on
A6 is that going to fall
he's gonna take it and he took it I was
about to say I think it is because I
just don't see a6a5 is really light onto
the pond
I mean
I'm not
very happy for Duda I think he's been
outplayed uh by the ever Wily and very
very tricky MBL he has been outplayed
yeah and now we see why MBL is leading
in the blitz as he swindled upon out of
a
this was robbery this was robbery he
might be clear daylight you know like
what happened I mean he didn't want to
get tied down to the V7 Pawn but it's
better than losing a point now do that
is going into his usual less than five
seconds for the next 30 moves okay 25
seconds and then counting by the way
this setup a potential nasty skewer with
Rook a a check followed by Bishop A5 so
don't allow that tactic
and he's played Queen B5 sides stepping
the threat ten seconds for do that one
minute and five seconds for mvl
I just feel like against these super
elite players you just can't put
yourself in a position where you're 30
seconds behind uh you feel the pressure
of the ticking clock forever Bishop
takes F5 a huge decision mvl spotted a
weakness on the king side and he
followed it up with G4
I'm
and I'm just being told that the
Magnificent streak of the swanathon and
non continues as Vichy has won his
fourth big moment in a row big moment
and in the position right now because E6
is a check but D4 D 5 D4 would block the
check with gain of tempo and I think
well there is still no Duda is back back
no other way of saying it but dude is
back he I mean at one time he was
getting outplayed now it's his turn to
outplay mvl and it's like whenever he
has five seconds on the clock he starts
playing brilliant joke yeah it's
incredible and Rook E4 to stop Bishop to
D4 and mvl found that very key move
and Bishop F2 what is the bishop doing
on F2 by the way notice the Rook on F5
is trapped
I'll tell you what he does yes sir it's
passing the time
good point
a move is better than no move and this
movement E6 that's a wake-up call that's
going to be because he's the G5 Pawn
with check no Rook to E5 yes that pawn
is going down on G5 I was thinking of
the bishop ending mvl made the decision
that keep the Rooks on the board he
wanted to keep the Rooks on the board
and he did and four three two what's
your impression is he's going to win
this mvl and weal is going to win this
because he's just a pawn up and he's my
goodness King goes to E4
wow I've got Rook D4 check I'll drive
you right back you could put the phone
on B5 that's what he did and he's done
it
three one you want to play Rook D5 and
he didn't get the opportunity because
King E4 would have hit the bishop and
The Rook but Rook C6 one flag oh is that
a flag no no four seconds five seconds
but D3 is hanging so it's over it's over
now
and you can play the moves but there's
no way you're gonna save the game Bishop
goes to C5 and we see a resignation a
huge game for mvo Wow any remaining
games we don't have no remaining games
all games are over
nepo has made a draw but go ahead and
tell us the all the results as MBL our
tournament leader maintains his lead
let's go to Maurice first
he starts from Zagreb and then we're
going to understand what the results
were in this round Maurice what do you
have for us good enough
simply an amazing round back and forth
mvl kudos to him for winning that game
he needed it because one Anon is surging
indeed just get to the story of the
round no question about it it was right
here after the move C4 Anan was pressing
the youngster the youngest player in the
tournament Jordan van forest and here
instead of taking on D4 and eliminating
this dangerous Pawn he played Knight
back to C6 D5 expanding in space if he
dropped back his knife and simply
captures and C5 and watches rolling with
a typical King's Indian type attack but
instead he decided to do something even
worse he gifted on a pawn and I said
okay I'll take that wait wait wait a
minute I'll take that one and I'll play
Knight F3 what are you gonna do about
your d-pod donate it is what you're
gonna do takes takes and Knight takes on
D4 a clean pawn and his technique was
superb will jump late into the game
right here where he's now actually up
two pawns and he played the Smashing
Knight takes on F7 Knight to D4 trying
to win a piece no can do Knight takes on
8-6 with check saving the Knight takes
and Rook to G3 check critical point of
your King's about to get nated and if
you suck your queen saying well I'm
hitting your queen well the Intermezzo
Queen D5 check now give me your queen
and that's game anahan just playing
Amazing chess right now absolutely
overtaking nepo who drew against
grischuk so Anna now in clear second
right behind mvl a big game we saw the
streaking chakra mom Madeira of he was
doing so well five and a half out of six
and then he got to this critical
position right here and just a simple
hanging proposition let's call it simple
but it's what it is and then he blamed
like we be one thinking let me just get
my queen out of the way uh-uh Garbo said
not a good idea two pushes and upon
sitting on C3 and the bishop played back
to A1 the bishop stayed on A1 for the
rest of the game basically I mean just a
mauling we're gonna watch this game
because it's such a beautiful attack H3
played
bam sacrificed by karabov hello King
takes on F2 Queen H4 and look at that
King side come under attack Knight to E2
and now Queen G5 not the most accurate
move here he could have taken on C3 in
this position the correct move
apparently he's queen of six check with
vicious attack after the move King to G1
you could continue with of this this by
the way nobody's finding takes takes and
this attack is supposed to be crushing
nobody's finding that that easily he
played
Queen to G5 but Rook D4 allowed the next
night sack Knight to C4 what a move
hitting the E3 Pawn if you take here
then simply check and gift me this guy
and the attack is sizzling you take care
then you lose your rook and again look
at that Bishop on A1 just a horrible
piece
Queen G5 Rook D4 Knight C4 he played
Queen C1 instead give me the pawn on E3
and now he tries to deflect the black
queen look what's going to happen next
in this game King G1 give me the bishop
on C2
now Queen C2 is met by Bishop takes G3
and the Knight is pinned it cannot move
because if Rook takes give me that and
again look at that sad Bishop on A1 so
instead after Knight takes C2 he
attacked the queen and he said I'm
sacking a queen is what I'm doing give
me that and look at this dominant
position Queen D1 Bishop G3 Queen D4 and
I want you to take a look at this poor
Bishop on A1 simply completely out the
game this game ended in just great Style
I want to jump ahead Bishop F6 Now The
Rook is hanging on E1 as well Queen
takes and the attack is surging again
he's basically up a piece but look at
this finish Rook takes King up check and
the Hunt is on
repeating moves now checking Bishop CA
check and that's going to be all she
wrote Because if you play King to F4
then simply Rook F2 check and the rest
is done chakra majirov's Dreams Just
Busted by one curabov
but it's all about Anan and guess who
play in the next round it's Shaq versus
Anand this she's showing his stuff what
a change in the fortunes of this
tournament remember what it was like
guys at the very top it was nepo leading
followed by mvl followed I think by
Anish where did Vichy come from and
where did nepo go incredible with these
nine so far seven rounds have produced
guys wow my head is thank you Maurice my
head is really spinning uh as we see
these uh rise and fall but let's take a
look at the standings so we can see
what's going to happen in these
Championship rounds that are coming up
oh wow Maurice I will tell you where
Vichy came from he came from winning
four games in a row wow and just a
destroying and keeping Pace with mvl in
the blitz portion 11 points a piece
right now in second position one point
behind Maxim vashir lagrav Jane ponies
falling off of Grace with 19 and a half
points one point and a half behind the
leader this is going to be a difficult
lead to uh catch up with but round 17 is
coming up next and we have some amazing
matchups for you guys we have Gary
Kasparov against Maxim vashir lagraf and
Yasser I think this is going to be our
Marquee matchup of the rock it really
has to be but we got to look carefully
at the bamidara versus Anand as well if
Shaq had won against Anton who upset his
dreams he would have 19 and a half and
the tournament would be wide open shot
was my pick and of course continue with
the rest of the uh the pairings I think
we're definitely going to be looking uh
for both of these matchups Gary Kasparov
versus mvl and mamadiara versus Anan but
we do have also Duda versus nepom nyashi
crucial crucial match up for the
standings Grisha versus Jordan van
forest and Anton korob versus Anish giri
and let's just take a little peek about
the final round as well because this
Championship rounds my gosh it's close
to the top Christian oh oh my goodness
we're going to have Max invest your leg
versus corabov nepom nyashi versus Gary
Casper of Anand versus grishup you see
all the leaders right now the top three
positions are playing with the white
pieces that's going to be an explosive
round depending on what results these
players need in that incredible very
important last round giri against mamad
yarov and Jordan band Forest finishing
up that round against Duda but
everything to play for yes and picking a
winner mvl in pole position before we do
that yeah I think we have a segment that
I think you forgot about and that is yes
there is uh oh my God ever won by
offering a draw do you remember that
place yes yes
trying to place the photo I'm not sure
I'm the president of the pond Grabber
Society Maurice you are the vice
president what about me yeah sir I don't
know we've got we need a Treasurer okay
yeah I mean we're getting lots of
donations we need a treasurer
chess is tough and then you die that is
true that's just fact those are the
facts I'm here just to tell you the
obvious and I do believe we have a
t-shirt of that sometimes your brain
feels like a Ferrari but only when
you're playing chess
and not when you wake up at six o'clock
and not when you wake up and finally you
won't hear this on Jeopardy
and that was pretty good now in
reference to what what did I say that I
I think I was it it was actually in this
round yeah that happened in this round
now I'm gonna have to go look at the
tape and you have to check the tape yes
sir and I just got to say that we do
want to still find out the mystery what
happened with Kasparov and Vichy but we
do have the game between
I believe
um mvl and Kasparov is that going to be
our Marquee that's the one Casper with
the white pieces we saw in the first day
of Blitz Kasparov had a crushing
completely winning pack completely
winning uh advances I think it was where
the engine was saying something along
the lines of plus nine against NVR mvl
swinged that game and won finally that
was it was a great crucial crucial
victory for him
but let's see the end of The Duda game
and how he plays every single round
without no time he goes to that five
seconds uh situation and then he just
plays brilliant chess but unfortunately
for him this time it didn't work out
exactly I think this move Bishop D4
wasn't the intention was to get in Rook
to D5 Rook D5 would have been and one
second by the way when he made that last
movement he made it unfortunately one
seconds on the clock yeah Rook C6 is one
second uh pigment a winner Bishop B4
check very important
intermezza move before capturing the
barn on D3 no King C5 for you and after
King takes D3
King
and it's all over
very very nice technique by mvl at the
very end as we're approaching our
Championship rounds two games remaining
and the tussle at the top is tough we
need a quick break we'll see you on the
other side
foreign
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the grand chess tour we
are entering our Championship rounds
round 17 coming up but let's very
quickly take a look at our tattered
predictions and
I'm gonna say I was very very close on
this one you are close on this thank you
yes thank you and my Blitz prediction I
was pretty close too at least in the
overall standings but unfortunately my
boy Anish is failing me right now
towards the end Anish come on well
Maurice is doing great with The Pick of
mvl but his overall pick nepo has faded
my guy was Rising Shaq was coming up but
one Anton uh just knocked him backwards
in the previous round a moment ago Shaq
had nine and a half points he was going
to go to ten and a half he got slipped
up and look at the blitz scores between
Vichy and MBL 2900 3000 tprs these are
amazing scores that is what I call a
tight race yes
and our overall current standings as the
players at the board we got we've chosen
the Marquee matchup between Jerry
Kasparov and mvl maybe we can even give
updates in the middle of the games as
well from the other very important game
and that is the one between
vishwanathan Anand and Grace Chuck that
is exactly we'll rely upon sorry
on the left Vichy of course on the right
we will Rely Upon Our colleague Maurice
to keep an eye on that but we will
follow Gary Kasparov versus mvl as MBL
is our tournament leader Knight F3 by
Gary
the same approach this uh English
opening with C5 okay B7 B6
uh not the 1965 that he had played
against uh grishock I believe and we are
mixing it up with uh B6 sorry Christian
no I believe he is mixing it up but for
a very uh specific reason and I think he
wants to win this game absolutely the
double fee in Shadow line uh Gary again
has had so much history uh with this
double line double fee and Shadow line
castles Bishop G7 D4 takes Queen takes
and also I'm thinking about his
countryman's Sergey kariakin also uh
play Knight takes I think Queen takes
was met with Knight E4 isn't that the
problematic Queen takes his met what
queen takes Knight E4 or 19 G7 isn't
defending oh he's not defended not yet
I'm with you 100 all the way good
morning good morning St Louis what we
call it around here we have had early
early wake-ups now this ending I
remember a column written by Grandmaster
Powell Benco
and he loved to get endings and what
he'd like to do pal that was is to play
E3 and queen F3 in order to trade off
Queens but Gary's approach was to play
F3
Knight takes Queen takes now Bishop E3
Bishop B2 has a problem because the
Knight is pinned now what Gary's idea is
is to play Rook to see one and to try to
keep that Knight on D7 in a very passive
uh position also do keep in mind that
this bishop on G7 is hitting an empty
diagonal as soon as white vacates the
diagonal with the move looks he wants
before we jump into the analysis I think
we should uh get an update on the other
game as well the one between my media of
and vishwanathan really quick to see how
they're looking in their game if we can
get a bird's eye view it's hard to see
from the side but there it is bird's eye
view Aston
presented okay the double pawns on the f
file
Shaq has dominance over the E5 Square
Bishop on B7
I I'm preferring White
I have to say I am preferring a white as
well specifically because of that Bishop
on B7 which is right now locked up
behind the pawn wall exactly and the
Knight goes to E5 the pawn goes to B3
and more or less this she has a vision
has to trade nights now keep in mind
that she has to win to stay in the hunt
for first place and Juan Wesley so is
saying come on nepo come on vishy take
as many Grand chest horror points away
from the tour players as you possibly
can and we're going to keep an eye on
this one let's uh move back to the Gary
kaspora versus NVM well Gary has gotten
what uh
pal benko would call the slightly better
ending as
his Rooks patrolling the open files the
C and D files
um is what's giving him the edge the
bishop on E3 was needing protection so
it just dropped back to F2 allowing for
moves like Queen to C4 you don't want to
drop the e-tube pawn the move you really
want to drop in on is Queen to D7 but
you don't want to lose the E2 Pawn for
that so Queen C4 and then one of your
Rooks ends up on the seventh ring and
you hope it'll be good enough to bring
Victory
um it's it's
feels tiny Christian it's a tiny but
what does impress me or is not
necessarily impresses me but I do want
to say I'm happy to see right now is the
time management by Gary right now he's
keeping in contact with mvl on the clock
three minutes and 14 seconds for Gary
three minutes and 18 seconds for mvl
okay any Queen trade Queen text Rook
takes the file that you want to dominate
as white is the C file your happy
trading Rooks on the D file then your
Bishop will go back to E3 controlling
the business Square D2 but you want to
land your Rook on on the C7 square and
that's what Gary is aiming for in this
ending he's just play Queen C4 inviting
the trade of queens and he's hoping
against hope that his Rook will land on
C7 there's Bishop on F2 will hit the
pawns on B6 and A7 and he'll have the
much Superior ending if he can get the
Rook on C2 and keep a rook on A8 mvl
that's the position that mvl has to
avoid and that's the challenge how are
you going to do it let's see uh the onus
right now is on the defender because
definitely not going to be better in
this position Rook to d8 was played so
inviting this exchange of the roofs
we're probably going to see them off the
chessboard in just a second Rook takes
the eight or takes eight and then Rook
to D7 exactly very important so Rook
tray tray trade uh then as white what
you're going to see is with the Rook on
D7 you want to play A4 B4 B5 you want to
establish your pawns on A4 and B5 so
that you always have a Target on A7 and
B6 let's see uh if Gary can keep this
positional pressure up so far
and that's what why not Rook to D2
I was expecting Rook today too Rook to
D2 you take on A7 that is a problem you
take on A7 who takes C2 and then King
King F1 and the pawn on B7 B6 is hanging
okay that is a big big problem because
if I manage to take that point on B6 you
can take the pawn on H2 as well Kid Rock
on the second rank take the pawn on H2
at the end but that was connected are
going to be very difficult to uh catch
uh agree what happens now after Bishop
E3 that is a good question Bishop E3 in
case of Rook D6 I do have Rook B7 Bishop
E3 Bishop D4
might be the save and let's jump back to
Maurice for a quick quick update in our
other key game Maurice
well the very big game between Shakira
and vishwanathan Anan had Vichy on the
back foot but he seems to have survived
the move A5 you can see here white just
has dominant space the H file is open
he's able to bring his pieces to that
side he could have played Rook H one
year natural move just go on the attack
instead he decided to sacrifice a piece
thinking this is going to win the game
by direct means and Vichy said I don't
think so get your queen off that
diagonal shark must have overlooked this
the point of the move A5 and now Queen
E3 give me the piece on E2 and now
Knight to B5 hitting the pawn on D4 and
saying your knight on G6 is still
hanging this sacrifice did not work he
played F5 going all in Queen takes D4
now Queen G5 a wild attacking position
at the moment guys but Vichy looks like
he is defending with the move queen of
six should be able to survive this one
although actually now it looks like
there's some crazy craziness going on on
the board I don't know if you want to
stay on this one instead of switching
back to the other game
well stay with it because this game has
all the excitement going on whereas on
the other game unfortunately it's rather
a dry Rook component game still
Advantage uh Gary Kasparov no question
about it but what happens
with the Vichy games I think she might
be winning his fifth game in a row I
could this would be unbelievable of a
comeback wow
that would be that would be just he's
just been climbing those standings what
can you say since the beginning of the
day it's just incredible to watch okay
and I've got the game of Vichy this is a
Donnie Brook I I mean I'm still trying
to
I'm counting actually accounting
material keep counting
the the Knight just hit the Rook
so this is a big deal there is the move
G5 but the problem is when I play the
move G5 Mike The Rook hangs the queen is
hanging maybe that Rook is hanging the
night is hanging like I just everything
is hanging
what is that move help me out here he
wants to play G5 move he wants to play
G5 and that's a chakra
seriously uh he's a great coffee house
player is Shaq but he's Queen just a
very gifted
wait a minute what is happening
tactician there are some tactics
definitely uh going okay which what
Knight H4 so okay this is a move it
takes takes on E6
Shaq is
I
whoa Vichy just hit him with a heck of a
shot no but because the Rook is that
comes back
oh The Rook comes back just in time to
hit the Knight he's won his material
back what's the pawn count it's equal
for the moment but I will get that pawn
on it though wait what
no she has to she wanted to play the
move Rook C2 why not Rook C2 was
absolutely the best movie wasted
such an important Tempo he's actually
now worse or probably still drawn I
think we're going to see uh but this one
he needed that Victory Yasser yes he did
that Victory yes he did Rook to B5 but
B3 check e three and B2
and
we have an easy rook and Potter in-game
draw let's go to the other one
absolutely
whoa I think Vichy missed an opportunity
there huge opportunity what's happening
on this one
a hurricane game as well
with a pawn up for Gary who is to move
right now
I think this would be a draw
a draw as well not sure how the H6 that
pawn I take that pawn on A5 I'm not yes
you do Rook takes A5 Rook H4 Rook A8
and that's a dead draw okay eight no
problems for me so our two very very key
games are likely to end in a draw how is
nepo doing because nepo was also still
uh let's say on the hunt he's still
playing but let's uh let's just finish
this one just to make sure that we're
not getting any other results by the way
my mediarov versus Anand has ended in a
draw as expected and that Game Shack
wait oh my goodness Gary lost on time no
mvl wins the game on time and signs
seals the deal that is it
oh my goodness let's jump quickly to the
end of The Duda versus nepo game what oh
my god oh
everything went wrong the wheels came
off completely
for Gary this is looking good for uh
Duda oh there's a Checkmate threat
Knight takes A3 that's a check two
seconds Knight to C2
you're giving up everything but there's
nothing coming back
game is over has taken down nepo as Napa
faded badly in the second day of Blitz
and that
Yasser I believe we do have a winner of
the event
we will have to confirm that in just a
second with our producers but I do
believe because yeah with this video he
did need a win to keep contact with him
and still be within striking range
mvl is the winner of the Third Leg of
Croatia of the grandchester the Croatia
rapid and Blitz congratulations mvl
Maurice called it all the way he did he
did he did MBL uh showing his his stuff
oh my goodness
I can't believe that Gary flagged in a
rook and pawn and game with two pawns
versus two pawns what how many seconds
does he have at this moment at this
moment he has 12 seconds and it's mvl's
man mvl's 12 seconds
I mean and you get a two second bonus
you play okay they say five okay and now
you play anything King E3 H7 anything he
started with 13 seconds and it just
froze and it keeps going what we did
before against we against uh Vichy as
well he just froze he forgot about the
clock
shocking wow
shocking wow and as
as mvl said yesterday in the same
situation when he won against Gary
Kasparov a little undeservedly came back
from a lost position I'll take the point
you will take the point that wins the
tournament for exactly you know you feel
sorry for Gary of course because this is
just a drop
black still had probably a slight
Advantage because that H Pawn was going
to fall but the two versus one is such
an elementary draw that he would have
had absolutely no problems uh making a
draw in that position agreed he just
forgot about the time yeah simple as
that and it's it's unfortunate to see
that but this is what comes with
inactivity that rust is extremely
difficult to dust off no question about
it uh when you're not competitive at the
board playing in one tournament after
another as the tour players do then you
tend to do something really really silly
like forget about the clock it happens
to the best of us even when you're on
the tour when you're Rusty then it shows
even worse
round 17 but uh one round remaining
Maurice our congratulations to you for
your accurate call
well not quite I called mvl winning the
blitz uh not winning the entire event I
had nepo winning the event
but I did call the Blitz
but I gotta say
it's really sad to see it happen this
way you saw mvl himself feeling like wow
how do I win this kind of position
really tragic for Gary Kasparov to lose
in such a fashion playing a great game
I'm just checking to see who's walking
by Gary's usually walked by uh this
booth many times before but I haven't
seen him go by at all so far a really
sad sad end to how he played this day
could have easily gotten yet at least
another half point but what can you say
we saw nepo fade we saw Anan search but
not get enough a big game for him Ana
did not win that game but fairly chakra
was winning the game as well so both of
those just canceled each other out
eventually
mvl to deserve a champion I gotta say he
didn't do that much today to win he got
three wins I believe out of all the
eight games but it was enough as nepo
faded and the other players just had too
much ground to make up so kudos to him
he will get 13 Grand chess tour points
I'm sure Wesley so is very happy to see
mvl of all the tour participants get it
and that was a question of how many
points can chakra Salvage to make it
competitive against Wesley for the grand
chess tour fight as we head to St Louis
after this guys thank you Maurice for
setting this that up first so very uh
succinctly as it is about grantchester
points the player who gardeners the most
number of points at the end of the grand
chess tour points uh will get a hundred
thousand dollar bonus and this third leg
is coming to a close we have one more
game left the tour will move on to Saint
Louis where we'll have the rapid and
Blitz in the sink field but we have a
summer of Chess ahead as we have our
winner Maxime Bashar lagrav speak to
this winner Chris what an amazing
comeback by the Frenchman it was all
about young nepomnyashi going in to the
blitz section nevertheless Envia was
keeping close all the time and once that
Blitz started they were jockeying for a
position at that poor position in the
first place and of course we've seen
Maxim vashir lagrav just keeping the hot
Pace burning and unfortunately for
Rihanna pumia she was unable to keep up
the pace we've seen so um so many
Amazing Stories emerge from this one one
of them in particular of course
but it was all about the Frenchman he
knew he had to win this event and he did
yeah winning on demand it's so hard at
the highest level but mvl
you just got to tip your hat he played
very very consistent throughout but in
the Blitz and especially he was very
very good
but we have the summer of Chess so much
more to come the U.S junior us junior
Championship the US girls championship
and the senior championships all of
those events are coming July 15th to
26th we'll play here in St Louis at the
St Louis chess club and Scholastic
Center then the grand chess tour picks
up again August 10th through the 16th
followed by the final fifth leg of the
grand Chester or the Sinclair cup the
granddaddy of the mall August 16th
through the 27th that will be followed
by ultimate moves and then Chess at 9lx
that's Fisher random for those of you
not in the know September 8th through
the 10th and then finally October 5th
through the 19th our favorite event the
U.S and U.S women's Chess Championship
Christian we got so much chess coming
there's a lot of Chess uh being uh
provided to you guys by us here at the
same and the grand chess tour but also
our partners at
casparovchess.com and there is a promo
if you have been enjoying the show so
far we do have a 30 off promo with code
GCT Croatia the platform is just amazing
you guys have a scene we've given you
some previews of those beautiful
documentaries the lessons provided by
the best coaches entertainers and chess
players in the world of Chess we have so
much amazing content at Casper of
chess.com and you can take advantage of
that with 30 off using Code GCT Croatia
and of course uh also we have
grantchester swag merchandise that are
available at cubatique St louis.com
and with one game our final round to go
here are our standings our
congratulations to MBL who has won the
tournament but the fight for second
is the third and all of that money
that's up for grabs 150 000 in prize
money Christian how do you reckon this
is going to shake out well Max
congratulations once again from the
bottom of our hearts what an amazing
event for the Frenchman vishwanathan
holding on to that second position he
needs to finish
strongyashi and Anish giri are going to
fight for that third position but maybe
yarov will creep in in that third
position this is going to be an exciting
nail biting finish exactly Shaq at 19 to
20 if you were to win he could
potentially LeapFrog some of the players
this wanna Thunder nun with a victory
could secure second or you know even
with a draw
absolutely very nice
and now we have time for one of the Gary
Kasparov I want to say Kasparov
chess.com lessons we'll see you on the
other side of the break for our final
round
[Music]
[Music]
you're about to see two absolutely
brilliant examples that will blow your
mind in this position black has an extra
piece that is controlling very important
g187 diagonal however with so many pawns
on the board white has no problems to
draw this game but can white play for
more yes he can white is setting up a
trap that one could never imagine to
fall for white is using the momentum
that the bishop is on F2 and it is
possible to block G1 A7 diagonal if
white does it simple with King D2 the
idea is E3 then black has time to go
back Bishop A7 and black easily draws
this game as after King B3 King B4 King
B5 black grabs the A6 Pawn
so white does it in a very powerful way
F4 sacrificing the pawn and forcing flag
to react now black should either take
the pawn on F4 or play E4
E4 would make White's life very easy as
it is impossible to control two pawns so
white simply pushes F5 King P3 F6 King
A4 F7 and if King B5 black is not in
time because f8 and queen is on the
board
but if Bishop C5
then we should distract this bishop and
play A7
now we want A8 so black should take the
pawn bishop takes A7 and now f8 Queen
and white is winning
so let's take a look what happens if
after F4 e takes F4
now white plays very strong E4 allowing
and Passat and the idea is same white
wants to push the pawn and it will be
impossible to control both A7 and E7
squares
so Empire C3
and now after King E2 white managed to
blockade G1 A7 diagonal and A6 spawn is
Unstoppable
now let's take a look at another example
that is a composition by Leonid Google
in this position white has two extra
pieces but unfortunately for white they
are not coordinated which makes very
difficult to stop the a pawn it is black
to move and black pushes the pawn A3
now how to stop the pawn
Knight C6 a very powerful move which
makes life easy if black plays A2 then
simple Knight B4 check and Fork White
wins the pawn
but of course this Knight is hanging
King takes C6 now what happens we
distracted the king
from D4 Pawn and white plays Bishop F6
the idea is clear if A2 Bishop takes D4
and we control the A1 Square
if King C5 then we win the A3 Pawn with
Bishop E7
so this leaves us with King D5
and again how to stop the a pawn now
white plays very subtle and a very
strong idea D3
what happens A2
C4
now white is setting up a trap if Amazon
D takes C3 Bishop takes C3 we control
the A1 Square there is no more promoting
the queen and we have extra D3 Pawn so
white is winning
so after C4 black should go King C5 to
be close to D4 upon because if King C6
then simple Bishop takes D4 wins so
after C4 King C5 and now the Trap
King B7 what is the idea of King B7 to
control this C6 Square why do we need it
because in case of Queen A1 Queen then
Bishop E7 suddenly is a mate
and otherwise black is in sukswang
because after King p7 either black has
to push the pawn or move the King and
King B4 Bishop takes D4 simply wins the
game
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the Croatian Zagreb
grantchester event it's been tough uh
the
the final day of Blitz has featured so
many amazing and crazy games and the
jockeying for position that I've kind of
lost track of everything that's been
going on Christian bailed me out with
our current standings well we're kind of
speechless if I were paid to speak right
now so we're trying our best let's look
at the standings right now we have Maxi
investor Le grab the crown Victor of the
Croatia rapid and Blitz vishwanathan
amazing results
incredible result
keeping up pace with the youngsters not
only that but simply I would say
dominating alongside Max invest your
graph in the blitz section 20 points and
a half one point ahead of yanepomnyashi
and Anish giri one and a half points
ahead chakri armo mediaro and Jan
Christophe Duda who are sharing the
fifth position then we have Alexander
grishook in the seventh position with 17
and a half Anton corabov with 15 points
and a half in eighth position Kasparov
slash sarich with 12 points and Jordan
van forest with 10 and a half points and
still lots of fighting for the money
let's have a look here 37
502 mvl that will certainly help line
his pocket with the fight for a second
Vichy Pole Position looking at a nice
payday of 25
000 third
2015 and so and so but it's also about
the grand chest tour points on your
right 13
go to mvl as
as the games are underway uh the wild
cards do get money but well the grand
Chester points they can't really uh cash
them in and sorry we didn't even pick a
marquis let's go with Vichy Yasser
because he needs to secure that second
position absolutely he's the only one
that can be caught by the third place
players right now and this she is
playing against Alexander grishuk
Alexander Grisha and we do see a trade
of the Rooks a vision knows that with a
draw he's going to secure second place
so I think he's going to try to get an
easy game exchange some pieces and make
a quick draw gotcha
but let's see I might be wrong result
for sure
played a rather quiet event and okay
this is the Berlin where just as you
said that she is just seeking to trade
off a lot of pieces which he has done
and I've seen and numerous number of
games where you know something like H3
and rookie one and queen D7 and
everything gets hacked off the board in
rather conventional fashion and if you
are just tuning in you might be
wondering why we're not watching the
leaders game that of mvl well mvl
already won the event exactly nobody can
catch him and with a draw Vichy can
secure
uh Second Place Undisputed Undisputed
second place exactly
and by the way that was an interesting
decision he he could have played Queen
E5
and really taken uh yes or the players
are just trying to find a way to
exchange every single piece and queen to
E5 Knight to G7 what you cannot play
Knight to F6 because a queen takes that
six very nice they found a way they have
found a way and we the cleaning lady
yeah yeah well the cleaners just took
everything off the board and if once he
plays before B5 H4 H4 H5 uh no
uh h4h5 we can call it a complete
lockdown
and yes we are saying two players are
are saying it was fun congratulations
Vichy Anand on your clear second place
congratulations there it is and you saw
uh Sasha say he did ask him did you get
clear second yes I did well let me shake
your hand again You're great and this
she is
um now let's move to the battle for a
third position exactly between
and if I'm not mistaken is it Anish no
who is it
Gary no no Gary for sure not Gary
I mean
let's watch this game between Jane
pomnioshi and Gary Kasparov
okay in day one that was the disaster
for Gary as he lost the last
game of the day yesterday with the white
pieces as he played terribly in the
opening
right now he's trying to launch an
attack on the king side in this what
seems to be a Berlin game now is that a
Berlin
uh no I think it was actually opening
some sort of with C4 and B6 hmm
and quickly I'm just going to catch up
the players F6 F5 well at this exact
moment I would say boldly stating the
obvious Gary's doing fine there's
nothing wrong with his position
whatsoever Bishops of opposite color
good Pawn structure uh
decent development double pawns for
white
on this C3 and C4 squares
hmm
I would I would say even but I think
Gary is going to be happy with the
opening outcome of the opening F5 F4
would be my my way of playing it Gary's
looking at maybe taking on e4 and
castling short in order to try to put
his Rook on the F4 Square personally I
like the move F5 F4 a light gaming space
I like locking down the king side and I
like castling short as black and for the
moment he is also looking good on the
time more than three minutes and Jane
pomeyashi also around the three minute
mark
well it if it's taken him quite some
time some time to get
and there we go as they move faster
was better I played a lot of Blitz with
Gary over the years and I'm not used to
seeing him uh playing what I think
are easy decisions so slowly it's like
he's unsure he's double guessing almost
his every move he is indeed yeah and
that you know that's a natural
repercussion of being inactive it's
always going to happen you can feel it
after six months of not playing chess
but when you're not playing chess for
the past 20 years and you're only
playing you know an event here and there
maybe once every two years yeah this is
natural this is going to happen exactly
now again I'm sitting there thinking
that I'm castling uh
short Gary took Knight takes D5 and A5
what does yawn need does it draw no no
Yani is tied right now if I'm not
mistaken 19 points and a half I do have
to say I'm not 100 sure who he's tied
with he's with giri I'm being told they
are tied Jan and giri are definitely in
the race to secure that third place
position
right now after the move A5 I'm thinking
that if Yan wants to make a draw he can
simply play the move Queen B5 Bishops of
opposite colors that goes nowhere that
just basically says that's a draw offer
and as far I think as Gary is concerned
he wants to see the back of this event
and go you know like I'm out of here
let's get it going
and
and let's also jump to the other game
the one between Anish giri and mahmedi
yarov because that one is as important
and it looks much more complicated than
this one exactly
and we have to remind everybody that the
team between Gary Kasparov and Ivan
sarich right now is a team right and
they're going to share the prize money
they're going to share
um the accolades for the place that
they're going to finish it
and a big shout out to Yvonne sarich by
the way because he brought the team
an enormous number of points and great
success I mean he himself was very very
pleased with his own play now the move
Rook G6 is walking into a knight E5
uh Fork so you want to take with the
bishop and not leave the bishop
undefended now the Rick Rook will
probably drop down to G three it seems
like why would you want to provoke the
pawn to age not sure not sure I to be
honest I'm completely puzzled by uh this
decision by Gary I would have went to G2
H3 really really giving up the G file
just like that wow uh this doesn't seem
right a remarkable decision to my way of
thinking as he's just encouraging his
opponent to double Rooks on the G file
so you can land with devastating effect
Rook G1 check so let's go Rook G6
shock we are still pondering his
decision
exactly Rook to G7
and not just protecting the pawn on C5
so that it doesn't fall with a check and
he goes for the doubling on the G5 a
very important as far as I'm concerned
moves like D4 D3 you've got to keep a
very watchful eye and make sure your
king doesn't end up getting
um
uh stock but by the way look at this one
look on H3 exactly you were talking
about stock qualifying what's that Rook
on actually doing I mean that's no way
to treat uh a rook something on the D3
Square
uh is disturbing Anisha Niche knows he's
being outplayed but for the moment okay
but what's happening about Rook B1
doubling the Rooks on the first drink
a quick update nepo did draw his game
against Gary casparov if Anish wins this
he's going to leave her clear third oh I
don't like that decision whatsoever
Knight takes E3 oh
that was
now
protecting that point on C5 this is
giving Anish some good chances exactly
well first of all H4 is hanging let's
just imagine to C4 hiding that King on
C4 and making space more importantly for
The Rook to come to D3 and by the way
Rook takes H4
wow I mean
now he can no longer do it but the
bishop is on f ah you mean before with
the Rook on G5 yeah
exactly with the Rook on G5 and the King
was on D3
but H3 F2 is hanging on F2 because
you're going to be five that point on C5
and that is White's concept is relying
on the fact that the hook on F5 is just
simply stuck to the defense of the
crucial Pawn on C5 at the right moment
what white wants to do is play B4
I think you have to do something like
Bishop E7 is a problem you you lose the
D4 Pawn good point Rook takes D4 that
clears the cobwebs you are absolutely
right Christian
Rook H2
the players are stuck but you're right
that b B3 B4 Anish is the one with the
brakes
what is the times of the players because
I noticed that the the move Rook E2 came
within a uh an extra snap 20 seconds a
piece right now
okay it's getting nervy not to see two
and The Rook came to F1 does he know he
needs to win this one to take clear
second clear third clear third
again nine seconds for Anish he plays it
B4 opens up the position opens up the
opportunity for any result at this point
and by the way his rook and slide A3 to
pick up that pawn on A7 and he's done it
that's what he's going for I think I
think he's in pole position to seize
this game in a victory again third six
seconds Rook H2 that's a check what's
happening with that runaway views
development is going it's a runaway
Criminal
wins the game and takes clear third wow
for Shaq he was playing great through
the first seven rounds
and he slipped uh what happened in the
game of mvl not that from the position
of the Kings I do believe that mvl has
one
and to put an exclamation mark on a
fabulous tournament Victory and VL wins
his final game as well and I do believe
that concludes our event Yasser the
tournament officially the games of the
tournament are officially over mvl is
the winner of the event we knew that
before going into this round on the
second position we have Vichy who has
concluded his event absolutely in style
in the style of a former world champion
and Anish giri picking up the pace
towards the end and
overlappingashi who slowed down his
engine tremendously in the final portion
of the event and here's our winner of
the event
Grand Master Maxim vashire lagrav
beautiful performance in the blitz
portion that earned him the first place
and 37 500 US Dollars and more
importantly I well at least as important
13 Grand just two points and a much
needed Victory as we were explaining in
the first two events that Maxine played
he did not
impressed and he now with this clear
first he has put himself right back into
the that race for the GCT tour we are
setting up for some interviews with
Maurice and Zagreb will be just a moment
but I tell you for me uh this tournament
has left me at times simply speechless
and that's pretty hard I would say for
myself I I just thought it was great and
again I just want to give a very big
shout out to the Croatian organizers for
really putting up a marvelous marvelous
chess tournament I enjoy calling the
action with you Christian and with
Maurice very very much it was a lot of
fun big shout out to our colleague as
well Alejandro Ramirez who wasn't able
to be with us for this event Alejandro
you've got to come back quickly uh our
so our viewer numbers have gone through
the the roof and you need to save us
from our further success okay so hurry
back
that was a good idea
[Laughter]
somebody's on the zoom call but I'm not
I'm not mentioning any any names
but actually Alejandro obviously isn't
Sochi and he's doing his best to help
coach some of our Lady players including
Carissa uh yep Jennifer and Tata so
come on ladies uh bring back the gold
I'm not sure who uh whether he's helping
Carissa I do not think he is in fact but
he does have some students at his
university that he's coaching said uh he
is helping as well as status as you were
mentioning let's look at our predictions
one last time and see who emerged
Victorious after this event well we
gotta give it uh to Maurice because he
did pick mvl in the blitz I picked Gary
Kasparov and I was so very close your
choice of corabov I think was inspired
it really was uh he had he had he was
the underdog he was the underdog going
into the event but he put on what I
would say is a valiant fight and he gave
us some memorable games throughout the
event I have to say I really enjoyed
calling his games those uh searches for
his Mona Lisa as you were calling it
Yasser those were some amazing games and
he's always an Entertainer that's what I
like about corobal that's why I picked
him but Anish giri did finish in third
position did finish quite incredible
yeah so I have to say I'm quite happy
with my picks I picked Shaq and Anish as
we just witnessed uh won that 18th game
I don't know that if they would have
necessarily switched places with one
another if Shaq had won but again
remember Shaq came into this event with
13 Grand Chester of points from
Bucharest so it was important uh how he
finished but once again just a reminder
our tour and our summer of Chess
continues with the Juniors the girls and
the senior championships July 15th to 26
right around the corner then we have the
final two legs of the two 2021 Grand
chess tour here in St Louis of St Louis
rapid and Blitz the singtel cup August
16th through the 27th ultimate moves a
really fun trash talking event as team
Randy goes up against team wrecks the
champion Showdown that's Fisher random
chest 9lx September 8th through the 10th
and finally
October 5th through the 19th the
granddaddy U.S
Open championship and the U.S women's
Chess Championship it just seems every
year that I return to St Louis those
tournaments get stronger and stronger
and here are the final standings with
the money distribution Christian Maxim
vashir lagrav wins the tournament wins
13 Grand chest tour points and he wins a
lot of money 37
500 US Dollars
ten grandchild tour points and 25 000.
Anish giri eight grandchild store points
20 000 US Dollars
six and a half points GCT points he is a
wild card so he's not going to count
those points too much these are stolen
from the full tour players 13
750 US Dollars yeah increase stuff 2.6
and a half points the same amount of
money for him Shakira mamadiarov piles
up those grandchilds tour points five
more after a win in Bucharest he's doing
quite well in the overall standings only
five points go with his 13 that I was
only getting in 18 points is not getting
it done as far as Wesley so is concerned
so Wesley is saying five fine check you
got five please uh continue you know the
singfield cup and the Saint Louis rapid
templates are going to be very very
contested tournaments as we continue the
tour Alexander grish took four
grandchild store points nine thousand US
Dollars Anton karoboff three grandchild
store points he is a wild card so those
points are thrown off the window eight
you eight thousand US Dollars Casper off
slash sarich they're going to split the
price one seven thousand and two
grandches through points Jordan van
forest in the 10th position with one
grand Chester point he is a wild card so
it doesn't really matter and 6 000 U.S
dollars but let's go to Zagreb and
Maurice we're a special guest Maurice
take it away
we are with the 13th world champion Gary
casparo of the brainchild behind the
grand chess tour and much of what
happens here in Croatia Gary we are all
rooting for you we're all rooting for
you but somehow this tournament was not
to be
so it's easy to explain so it's not just
being Rusty it's just uh these guys are
professional and I'm an amateur so I
spent a little bit of time with Peter
swindler you know just a few days before
the tournament just going through this
opening Theory because you know in 960
I'm far more comfortable because I don't
have to overload my brains with you know
with all this opening Theory and I have
to say that in the last few days so I I
was shocked because we looked at some of
the positions that are analyzed you know
before some of the participants on this
tournament were born and then in in one
minute you know the the engine tells you
that everything I did you know preparing
for Nigel in 1993 is a crap
so it's some kind of shocking experience
because you know just I have to go over
it and and again I I probably could have
better job preparing but problem as you
know this is shifting from you know from
totally different things you know just
you know you know having a speech on
cyber security or recording message
supporting decisions in Iran I just do
you know and then you have to play guys
this is and they're the best guys you
know this is this this is their job and
uh and I'm you know it's you know things
could go better in the first day but
it's just you know and I was shocked you
know they just played Bishop G5 and I
all my life at liquid mistakes but now
to memorize this line so yeah and I
played
allows you increase the seven but I have
to say that you know that's this this
it's a I had decent positions you know
this it's it's in all games it's the but
I don't know if the time became a factor
yeah
this is the moment you know just I I sh
you know I was shifted to it to ground
that I I I didn't you know expect so I
just it's everything went you know just
in the wrong direction and um and
yesterday I was really strongly you know
just I probably needed some you know
spent a few days you know just playing
you know maybe I had to play with
Charlotte you know just you know uh to
uh just to feel the pieces so that's
it's it's the different things you know
it's I play a lot on online but it's
it's not the same and again it's still
the same strengths so and and you know
Peter today used to speak to swindler we
spoke and he said okay now something is
just you know is is kind of magic
because I did much better in the
training games you know just you know
when we played online so then I just did
here somehow the pressure and and also
this again it's steam I don't know it's
a it's I couldn't get back together and
and today this is the the first game I
was very proud I mean that was a great
game this is for Blitz you know with
Energies and then was then just second
round with Greece you can took on H3
even I could memorize it we analyzed
With Yuri and late eurody and this this
is 20 years ago and after Bishop B7
black has decent position yes it's an
exchange down but Bishop two pawns
Knight on D4 he knows black has is easy
to play with blood Bishop f8 Bishop C6
and again let let's see what white can
do and and then I just said oh my back I
can make a Brilliance and just throttle
boss and I still had a little bit of
steam left and then it was Duda you know
I
I I don't know I just I saw somehow I
touched the bishop I don't know why
touches the bishop after Queen Bistro I
think he would he would be um not dead
but it's just close to that and actually
instead of even Knight D4 to the problem
Bishop D4 was winning instantly but I
was over excited because it was a good
game to scan the energy and after this
game I just you know I I lost it and I
always wish I just you know I just
played yeah it's it's very it's like
I've lived like an amateur so you don't
play G4 and sacrifice on G6 Gary you're
no amateur I mean I understand the
current amateur you're a legend in our
eyes we know the history you have will
last for an eternity as one of the
greatest players ever to play which
still was
playing
so close you know so if we need to
rookie free and I think it's just you
know the way I calculated this probably
to me you know it's in many games or so
close yeah and then yesterday was nvl as
you talked about form is important
playing more you have so much that you
have to do a lot of sense of clock very
often so it was like MBL today so this
is the I that goes close but then it was
at the end of the draw and I just
totally forgot that you know we'll play
we'll play
play we play we play it's not just four
we just you know it's just it's it's
look four means that you know you you
can get better or worse but I'm not you
know not a professional player anymore
but you know this is if not my if not
being forced to analyze this this new
lines and just going through this crazy
Sicilians that that have to memorize so
much so I I think in Central Coast I
will do much better
forward I know I know I know that what I
can do and this is if I don't have to to
to to to to waste all my energy but to
memorize these lines I think I can do a
good better job your thoughts on the
fact that the tour now is expanding next
year we heard the announcement to be in
Poland it shows that the grand Chester
was alive and well with great
possibilities for the future well
absolutely absolutely
is is I think it's it's it's a very
important event for the world of shares
because it's it's professional it's it's
it's
um uh when I say professional it's not
about professional players but it's
about sponsors so we are building
something that will last and and the
fact is that we're expanding that sends
a message that you know this is this
format works and uh whatever people say
oh and this is that's the
uh online chess will replace everything
this is the the live share special
classical just as dead no actually not
so we know that Bucharest now loved
classical chairs so we have two events
for classical singers and Bucharest and
we keep adding tournaments for for rapid
and Blitz and um I think it's a great
excitement I'm doing the numbers online
you know that tell you that people still
like you know to see this the Gladiator
spirit
if you go like seeing you one of the
greatest Gladiators ever thanks so much
for coming and standing up with us it's
Gary kasparo of the 13th world champion
the Visionary behind the grand chess
tour guys back to you thank you Maurice
thank you Gary and let's take a look at
our grand chest store
as standings with this the third leg in
the books Christian what do you have for
us well we have a maxim vasher lagrav
with 22 points just a fraction above
Wesley Wesley still has an event to play
that's the big problem Maxi vasher
lagrav has played all the events so far
in the grand Chester he's going to take
a break now for the St Louis rapid
templates and will return with the
singfield cup 66
000 250 not a bad price one so far
Wesley so of course he has been
dominating grandchester so far he's just
been doing amazing 21.3 points what
about my pick for this tournament uh
shackery are hundred thousand dollars in
the pocket 18 Grand Chester points keeps
him within Striking Distance of Wesley
with the sink fill Cup and the rapid and
ballista play oh absolutely that is not
bad at all then we have in fourth
position Levon aronian with two events
played and 13.8 crunches poor points
quite a nice uh amount of pocket change
as well absolutely Alexander Grisha
coming in with 12.3 points maybe he
needed something more than what he got
out of zagra but 54 000 Point fifty four
thousand dollars pardon me and honestly
two events played 10.5 points GCT points
and 32.5 thousand dollars Fabiano
caruana can't be happy can't be happy
Christian only a mere seven points for
the world's number two ranked player
come on that is not a good result for
Fabiano and he's definitely going to be
ultra motivated to do well in his
hometown exactly in St Louis
in eighth position to even fans played
six and a half points he could not be
happy either very unlucky Richard
Rapport unfortunately only played one
event why because he got ill nothing to
do with kovid but Richard unfortunately
had to skip book arrest that was why we
had this special Wild Card uh Christian
absolutely Richard unfortunately fell
ill only two days before the event so it
was just in the last moment
heartbreaking for him unfortunately he
will not have the chance to recover
those points because that was a
classical event and he's going to play
two rapid and Bliss events and
unfortunately for him just one classical
but we do have Maurice with another
guest in Zagreb Maurice
not just any guest it's the legendary
world champion vishwanathan Anand coming
in second place vishi you hadn't played
in 16 months you said you know you're
trying to get back into the swing of
things second place five wins in a row
how did you do it
it just happened I mean uh it I was I
felt I was playing well in the rapid but
um
obviously Anish uh I mean I'd come close
to saving it and then there was the
other loss but um
in the blitz I was apprehensive because
when you've been away for a long time
you don't know how you'll play but it
went fabulously yesterday already I was
pleased with the plus two
and today it came I started off
brilliantly I should have beaten both
Anish and dudha completely winning
positions and I drew both
and then you always you know they say if
you don't score someone your opponent
will so I was kind of nervous but
there's four Ruins in a row look I'm
happier than anyone else I can tell you
about four wins that I stand corrected
yeah remember those two wins you you
could have had in the first two games
that would have just catapulted you but
still the result is amazing you hadn't
played chess in all this time you ended
on a plane in all this time what makes
it come back you think to those
fingertips
it's a bit random I mean a thing here a
thing there and the tournament can be
different but
um
sometimes you just have the feeling that
the wind is near back and I want some
very nice games in the blitz I mean my
French with korbo when the blitz was uh
very nice yesterday
today was much choppier uh but still uh
I played well but I cannot explain why
your colleague
your big rival from back in the day Gary
casparov did not perform well your
thoughts about that
yeah he um
he really seemed to struggle uh
what was what struck me was I can't tell
the difference between the what 12 or 13
years he was away when he played Saint
Louis
and the
16 audience
after this tournament
but
um
the Gap was so big it said Lewis he
seemed like a jesler I mean he seemed
like a top chess player he knew his
openings he knew everything and he was
playing fast
um of course some drama happened but I
think but here he he just seemed out of
it completely and it was very surprising
in the opening ceremony to hear him say
that um
yeah trying to lower everyone's
expectations and I thought is that Gary
and we used to know uh and maybe that
was a kind of uh warning sign but I mean
it's clear this is not uh
this is not the Gary we recognize but I
was a tough thing and one thing I'll
give him credit for he didn't back down
on the last day he just kept going and
going so that that's still he's got that
what events do you have coming up that
your fans can look forward to
well in a couple of days I'll play uh no
castling Jazz with Glady in Dortmund
um
and after that I'm going to do some
commentary in the World Cup
so bits and pieces but I think this
result gives me a lot of motivation to
uh work again you know I really
sometimes you know good results just
lifts you and hopefully I'll be ready
when some tournament comes up now well
you know everybody says you should just
retire because you can't compete with
these guys but I think they're wrong
congratulations on a fantastic result
thanks the great vishwanathan Anand with
a resume anyone would be envious of
showing once again how brilliant he
indeed was can hang with the best of
them guys thank you Maurice and a big
shout out to vicious congratulations
thank you for being such an
inspirational figure in the world of
Chess fishy and what a great uh result
today it was wonderful but as this is
our final broadcast of Zagreb we want to
have some uh big thank yous and shout
outs to the people who make it all
possible the people that make us look
good yes yeah let's start with them and
allow us to broadcast this beautiful and
exciting event for everybody at their
homes of course I'm talking about a lot
of people so I'm going to read from a
list because my memory is terrible we do
have Spectrum Studios and Silverback
video those are the production companies
that have helped us
produce this event for you guys in
particular I want to thank uh the guys
in Zagreb Randy Kevin Marcus and Brian
and Jen who is here with us in the
studio in St Louis absolutely and from
my perspective I want to give a big
thank you to the people of St Louis
chess club and Scholastic Center they
make it possible for us we come in each
and every day early in the morning and
they're there I'll start with Emily she
is there each and every day not only
with breakfast but she takes our
temperature to make sure that we're
covid-19 free monitors us a big shout
out to Eric Dennis koshka Jonathan and
of course Tony Rich and joy Bray they do
such a magnificent job none of this
would be possible without the great and
generous support of Rex and Dr Jeannie
sinkfield big shout out Rex and Genie we
miss you we hope you will see you in the
next Grand chess tour but to all the
staff here at the St Louis chess club
and Scholastic Center thank you so much
and none of this will be possible
without our producers in the truck that
are helping us with everything are
whispering in our years we miss
something or whenever we have let's say
a brilliant result on the board and of
course those guys are Kevin the Pew Tom
Kita Jim Sean Nate Megan and will thank
you guys we appreciate it and back to
London says our producer back to Paris
no Tom it's the crucial Croatia's we're
getting ready in Croatia with Maurice to
present the closing ceremony the trophy
to mvl and so it's our great Fortune to
be able to be the first to congratulate
VL he played great he was just a
brilliant event exactly wow and I have
to say a brilliant event for him but
also a brilliant event for Vichy who is
the leader of a new generation of Indian
players yeah as a coach he's doing some
amazing training with a lot of the
generations and you can you can bet that
these guys have been inspired by this
performance quick question for you
question as a coach uh what's next for
you well what's next for me yeah sir is
actually I will be seeing you very soon
baby that's what I'm talking about just
a few days the summer of Chess continues
for us what are we doing we're doing the
Juniors 16 years and the girls
that's going to be a fun event I'm
looking forward to that absolutely for
me the senior Championship is like a
class reunion I mean uh those guys are
legends and people I look up to in World
Chess Hall of Famers so I'm gonna have a
lot of fun I'm already teasing them that
we've got the wheelchairs we got the
elevators
we got the booster cushions and anything
else that they could possibly need to
make their trip but it's so much more
enjoyable having a lot of fun of their
expense of course and of course after I
finish that I will be uh focusing my
attention on the University program that
I'm teaching at the University of
Missouri we have an amazing team of
players who are engaged in recruiting
and trying to get our players from
overseas to campus that's it that's the
problem the problem that we're trying to
solve right now but those players have
been just simply amazing doing classes
online occasionally and and uh yes that
is what I will be focusing on as we
finish with the summer of Chess exactly
for me of course I will be here uh
throughout our summer of Chess enjoying
a front row seat for these national
championships that are coming up for the
grant the two grand Chester events that
are coming up here in St Louis and of
course the U.S championships that's on
October so I just want to say it's
always a pleasure to have a front row
Seaton to work with yourself and Maurice
it's been a lot of fun I tell you and
unfortunately those early wake-up calls
uh you know any Anna analytical mistakes
we may have inadvertently made it was
because we were tired good morning
good in the morning St Louis keep the
coffee coming that's all I ask
absolutely I haven't drank this much
coffee in a very long time I am a
morning person but that was five o'clock
wake-up calls
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah pretty
hard delivery yeah yeah absolutely but
we've had some amazing games yes sir I
have to say we are so fortunate to have
this front row seats as you were calling
them it's the best job in chess as a
chess fan ourselves watch this amazing
players compete at the highest level is
just amazing but we do have Maurice for
the closing ceremonies hello Zagreb take
it away more inspiration rapid and Blitz
we have with us the executive director
of the grand Chester Michael kodakovski
Augusta dragic who is the president of
super United and of course our winner
Maxine vashiella grav Augusta we'll send
it over to you to give the wonderful
trophy
thank you congratulations first of you
um sorry
I want to tell you that you are one of
my favorite and I'm very happy that you
won and please take this very nice
Trophy and I hope to be also with you on
other many times when you will get rid
of trophy congratulations again
thank you so much for those kind words
Maxime you had some difficult events so
far on the tour how does this one make
up for those first two
it was very important for me just to
play well and to get back this sensation
of winning so yeah I'm I'm delighted
simply
this is great preparation as well you go
into the World Cup are you feeling great
about your chances
um well I have optimism on my side
always so I always feel good about my
chances even when I'm not playing well
so
here I'm definitely feeling good but
it's going to be an extremely tough
event I know I know this from experience
what was the Difference Maker for you
here in this in this tournament you were
always close but you seem to make a real
surge when it came to the blitz but what
was the difference between you you think
and the rest of the field
I think defense yeah defense is
essential especially in Blitz and I lost
only one game I should have lost
probably four or five but uh
yeah defensive skills let me escape with
only one loss well congratulations once
again guys a worthy Champion he says
defense wins championships we know that
to be the case but we have our winner
maxim vashilagrav of France the winner
of the Croatian rapid and Blitz back to
you in St Louis thank you very much
Maurice as we wrap up our coverage let's
once more go through the roster of
players starting in 10th position in
Jordan van Forest uh Christian Jordan
van Forest the Dutchman the 22 year old
youngest player in the event 10th place
and six thousand dollar prize money
quite a good event for him of course to
warm up and to start understanding how
it feels to play this place yeah it is a
very very top player is a great
experience indeed for the young Jordan
and Ninth position we have team sarich
and Gary Kasparov they will share this
seven thousand dollars a big shout out
to Yvonne for a great rapid Gary
you got to work a little bit more on
your Blitz
of course and in eighth position we have
one of the favorites of a lot of fans
out there the entertaining Anton core
above eighth place 8 000 US dollars he
did mention at the beginning of the show
that his wife told him you better get
some money bring it home at least as
much if I'm not mistaken as a yearly
average salary in Ukraine not bad not
sure if he did it but that's it let's
hope so in seventh position the ever
entertaining the great Alexander Grisha
seventh prize
a prize money of nine thousand dollars
and four grand chest tour points Sasha
they started being entertaining they
started off slowly but then definitely
picked up the pace one man that picked
up the pace in the blitz competition was
one shakuya mahmediarov who just played
brilliant chess today he started off
with five and a half out of six in the
end he finished in sixth place and
gathered ten thousand dollars and five
grandches tour points in fifth place Jan
Duda as he takes home 13
750 dollars in prize money is one of
those situations where you think to
yourself I could have done better I
could have done worse but he was
entertaining throughout oh absolutely
and such a fun player to continue
watching this is the new generation
Yasser and tied for fourth place with
Jan christoptuda
ishi the world championship Challenger
unfortunately for him he started off hot
he led all the way a Christian it was
amazing he did but he finished tied for
fourth and he took home 13
750 as a clear third place was Anish
giri as he takes home twenty thousand
dollars in prize money some nice Grand
Chester points eight grand Chester
points he'll be pleased with this event
as I don't think he really distinguished
himself in the rapid and he's off to the
World Cup as well
the time tiger 4 from Madras has been
roaring in the blitz section just an
amazing amazing accomplishment second
place 25
000
what a great player on us it's like a
fine wine he just gets better and better
with age our congratulations to the ever
young this one upon an island and our
first place winner mvl Maxima Charlotte
grav takes the first place 37 500
dollars undivided first place he gathers
an extra bonus Grand Chester appoint 13
to go along with his previous two events
our congratulations once again to MBL
and what are we talking about maybe 2
900 3 000 performance rating he won
about 40 50 rating points ridiculous
just an amazing event yesterday it was a
pleasure to call the action with you and
Maurice as always a real pleasure thank
you everyone body for sharing your day
your weekend with us we hope you're
enjoying the grantchester uh
to broadcast
please do check out our sponsors at
Kasparov chess.com as well as Q Boutique
we hope you've enjoyed your weekend
goodbye from St Louis goodbye
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]